going all right Mr chairman good to go
okay
as the chair of the house rules
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency cleared by the governor
result of covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically please note that there is
no physical location to observe and
listen contempor usly to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to
Governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that we are
providing public access to the meeting
by phone with additional access
possibilities by video or other
electronic means we are utilizing Zoom
for this electronic meeting all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contempor during this meeting through
this platform and the public has access
to cont listen and if necessary
participate in in this meeting through
dialing the following phone number
51631 or by clicking on the following
usj
dot by providing the public notice of
the necessary information for accessing
the meeting we previously gave notice to
the public of the necessary necessary
information for accessing the meeting
including how to access the meeting
using Zoom or telephone Ally this
information is printed in the house
calendar providing a mechanism for the
public to alert the public body during
the meeting if there are any problems
with access if there are if anybody has
27136 or email at
HCS legislative do state. new hampshire.
us adjourning the meeting that the
public is unable to access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting shall be done by R call
vote let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance when each member
states their attendance please also
State whether there's anyone in the room
with you during this meeting which is
required under the right to no
La pres Packard
yes and you are where I am I oh that's
right home alone uh by myself yep all
here thank you sir representative
Osborne uh here home alone in Auburn
representative
rice I'm home in my bedroom alone the
rest of them are in their prospective
rooms representative Stephen Smith
thank you I'm here in Charlestown alone
in this room my dog and son are
elsewhere in the in the
compound representative
sbor I am here in Bedford in my living
room on the phone by the way not on Zoom
right thank you uh representative
Cushing I'm at my home in Hampton I'm
alone in the room I have other family
members wandering around the house
representative shirtliff I'm at my
residence in Penacook and I am
alone representative Weber I am alone
and I am in
conquered representative Timothy Smith
home office in Manchester nobody else
here thank you m Mr chairman your
committee is all
present
okay help me out a little bit here Paul
do we go right to the uh yes Mr chairman
first thing you have is requests for
late Drafting and you have uh represent
you may ask speaker yes go ahead thank
you Mr chair as a preliminary uh matter
um there are a number of people who also
co- requesting the introduction of uh
legislation and can they participate in
committee um
I I don't think so uh uh Mr leader I
think you know why don't you make your
presentation and we'll go from there
okay um I would request uh permission
for a late introduction of a bill that
would amend the um the house uh to the
legislative uh Ethics Committee to allow
for a a provision um that there could be
to amend it to right now we have
Provisions that relate to um uh sexual
um abuse and misconduct and financial
and exploitative and this would allow it
to include um uh act actions that were
uh engaged in by members of the
legislature uh that would constitute um
violations that would that would be
considered um harassment uh of based
upon uh
specific conditions that are included um
in the resolution as I presented it to
you and I would ask that you allow this
to be in the reason that this is comes
as a late request is
because subsequent to the closing and
the filing period uh it uh became public
knowledge that a member had posted what
uh as I looked at it was kind of a vile
uh hurtful and um quite frankly
dangerous uh meme on Facebook page um I
think that's the that's the type of
activity that should not be condoned by
the legislature I think by making a
provision uh where it would be um that a
complaint could be filed with the um
with the Ethics Committee it would
provide for um for process a due process
for anyone who would be um for for whom
it would be uh the the the misconduct
would be um alleged and provide for a
mechanism to to hear that to gather
facts and make a recommendation akin to
the way that we deal sexual misconduct
akin to the way that we deal with
problems with you know self-dealing with
financial interest and it became
necessary because quite frankly I until
I saw that it never had I I could not
believe that that typee of uh you what
would be like hate speech um directed it
uh a vulnerable population would be
engaged in by a member of the
legislature
so are there any
question if there be no
questions uh representative Smith do you
have a
motion I do Mr chair I move to not allow
second representative rice I'll second
I'll
discussion okay with that the clerk will
roll the motion is to not allow a
drafting an introduction representative
Packard no I yes I'm sorry yes
representative Osborne yes
representative
rice yes Representative Steven Smith yes
Sor yes represent Cushing no
Representative shirtliff
no represent Weber no represent SMI
Timothy Smith
no the motion to not passes 5 to
four all right thank you what's next on
the list ball uh representative blazic
and I will um need to just promote her
to uh speak to you all if you give me
moment hello you are all set
representative BLC when the chair
recognizes
you uh
go ahead
representative thank you chairman um so
I am requesting late drafting for a
simple resolution to deem emergency
order 76
unconstitutional um obviously the reason
for late drafting would be that uh the
order wasn't signed until last
Friday um but it is unconstitutional it
was only in 2018 that the citizens of
this state decided uh to add a article
2B which protects their privacy and
everybody in the state should be able to
have their vaccination status private if
they so choose this order also violates
article
29 um in article 29 it states that only
the legislator May uh suspend law and
yet he has suspended multiple laws in
this order now this resolution is simply
a statement that the is here that we are
going to be willing participants in this
process and it is a reminder that he
does not have the authority to um
representative representative
Weber I'm I'm sorry not having anything
in front of me I am not not sure which
emergency order and what the content of
the emergency order is we're talking
about so this is emergency order 76
which was the one uh that made the
registry the vaccine registry um uh not
able to opt
out um for the purpose of the covid-19
vacine uh currently the way that the
registry is written um it is a voluntary
uh process when the registry was written
it needed to be voluntary to be able to
be constitutional and this eliminates
the ability for it to be
voluntary and my understanding is that
oh I'm sorry Mr may I have go ahead go
ahead resentative uh thank you and thank
you for taking my followup um am I
correct in understanding that although
the participation has become mandatory
there is no disclosure it's just the
particip ation that you're objecting
to correct correct so um everybody's
vaccination status will as far as the
covid-19 vaccine will now be tracked um
either they will be in the registry
because they received the vaccine um or
they will be in there because they did
not uh get the vaccine thank you very
much for the clarification thank you Mr
Speaker uh is there any further uh
questions for pres blazic
Representatives uh Tim Smith has hand up
Mr um go ahead represent Smith uh thank
you um I don't have this um proposal in
front of me at the moment is this
proposing the late Inu introduction of a
house resolution a concurrent resolution
or a joint
resolution it is a simple house
resolution again it's just a statement
um it would not actually be able to
resend we don't have the power to
actually resend an order this is just a
statement that we recognize you know
what's
happening any further questions for um
representative
Blazer okay there be no further
questions
um representative wasborn
do um so while are we allowed to discuss
at this point or do we need a motion
first or um why don't we get a motion
it Mr chair representative Cushing had
raised his
hand okay I'm sorry representative
cushion um Mr sh I'll move to not allow
it okay is there a
second okay representative Webber
seconds it yes now we can discuss the
motion go ahead representative Bron okay
so
um so on on this one I see the
um uh the matter of urgency uh just
because of the uh the timing of this
order Rel relative to our deadlines so
in in that respect I
um I can be agreeable to that um if if
it's just a a resolution that um doesn't
uh doesn't do anything I guess
guess that question yeah I you know I
just don't understand why um
having not recognized the urgency of
trying to do something when um hate
speech is being uh engaged in uh by
legislators and um not having a clear
provision on how to do it that the the
that that legislation was dismissed and
now um we want to see because someone
the government took action um we want to
allow that in I just don't understand I
want to at least have some consistency
in what we're not going to allow
in further
discussion senator Rice representative
Stephen Smith and then represent
B thank you so first of all my take on
this is um I'm not telling anyone what
vaccinations I get I I don't care what
executive order it is it's it's my
personal business and it's quite frankly
between me and my doctor but I don't see
the purpose of doing this I I I think
it's a posturing move but I it really
has no effect I mean I think the
governor knows how we feel about this
necessary representative Smith
thank you Mr chair um I disagree with
representative Cushing that this act
relates to the earlier one because we
already have a process in place to deal
with egregious ethics violations and
we've used it before so we know it works
in this case I mean representative BLC
has a point in expressing the will of
the house on something that happened
after the filing deadline and that's how
it's different um having said that the
res resolution bill will still go
through the whole process if we actually
wanted to do something about it couldn't
an amendment be introduced to one of the
other executive order bills to raise
this issue and have a discussion on it
without um going around the rules
process so I guess I kind of ended with
an inquiry of the chair or the
clerk
sorry well I I I will attempt to uh give
you what I perceive to be and then the
clerk can step in if I State anything
but I do believe that uh there's what
four or five bills that have to do with
the emergency orders uh Mr clerk am I
correct I've seen several lsrs um that
are are specific to the state of
emergency and and the various orders
deriving there
from okay
um personally I do not like the idea
whatsoever of a state regist
I I I'm afraid that um personal
information like that could easily get
out but I
also am concerned about the separate
resolution when something could be added
um kind of in a little quander about
this one myself because I agree with the
principle of it but I'm not sure this is
r i i I agree with you representative
Packard I think that let's let's try to
keep everything all together I don't
think there's a need to to draft
anything new let's add an amendment to
the already existing um executive order
legislation that's out
there okay representative Tim Smith has
his hand up Mr chair uh go ahead Miss uh
representative Smith Tim Smith yeah I
I'm I'm also inclined to agree um with
representative Packard uh you know I'm I
don't like speaking as a tech guy um I
have serious concerns about the privacy
of this registry um but I'm I'm not sure
that late introduction of a house
resolution that would not have the force
of law is really the vehicle to um
express our our feelings on that I would
be more inclined to support the late
introduction of a concurrent resolution
um than a house resolution and if if the
member would like to proceed with just
the house resolution I I think the
member can just move to suspend the
rules in so far as you know through the
normal process um and and let that play
out on the floor or add the amendment as
was suggested um onto one of those other
existing
bills I I oh go ahead representative
question no just an inquiry of the of
the cleric or or or or the the chair are
any of the legislation that are directed
at that that relate to the emergency uh
orders of the governor um are any of
those resolutions or are they all for
bills you
know um I can uh take a look if you give
me just a moment I mean I guess the
reason I I I I asking this is because I
know that under our rules the director
of legislative Services um when receives
a request from uh on a subject matter
from more than one legislator there's an
effort to try to get them to combine the
legislation and uh as I don't think
there have been any bills that have been
introduced or signed off on isn't the
isn't it a possibility that that the
that the individual could go to one of
the sponsors of the um what have already
been filed lsrs and seek to incorporate
the you know that language seek to
address that um executive order in that
um in what's already an existing LSR
um Mr chairman I do have the answer to
the question representative Cushings ask
if you'd like thank you yes please um
the lsrs that have been uh filed
regarding uh the the emergency um do all
appear to be HBS at the moment um and I
do want to just to to clarify um the
statute RSA 4-4 equal 445 um is is
specific that um a concurrent resolution
um can end the state of emergency period
um it does not speak to individual
emergency orders um so I I wanted to
clarify that and our our legal council
is on the line if you if you do want to
ask any questions there as well so if
I'm correct and what you're saying Mr
clerk is that if we accepted this it
would nullify all the emergency orders
no this this is so if it's a resolution
just a simple house resolution
stating a position of the house it does
not have any in fact force of law or
anything it is basically a a policy um
statement and representative Weber has
sir
oh you have your hand up representer
Weber oh okay I'm sorry go ahead thank
you Mr Speaker um I think that really
the nub of the matter is that we have a
number of vehicles the the if if one is
concerned about being added to the
registry you need a law to make sure
you're not going to be added to the
registry and it's very much a debate
worth having but we already have a
number of vehicles available to us for
that debate all of which can be amended
and all of which would have the force of
law passed by the house so for that
reason and being very sensitive to the
fact that adding more debate and more
time to our calendars is going to be
very difficult this year uh I am going
to vote uh in favor of uh denying the
late drafting in this case knowing that
there is an appropriate way that the
representative can address the issue so
that all of us can have a proper debate
on it and a final floor action if
necessary thank
um as I said I personally am against
this registry I I I have very serious
concerns about being able to keep safe
everybody's medical records and I would
rather see this myself in the
law and move
quickly then passing a resolution that
isn't going to accomplish anything uh
it's a basically a statement saying that
we disapprove of it um and I will say
categorically right here I disapprove of
it but passing a resolution at this
point to me it's it's it's making a
statement but it's meaningless I would
much rather see this into law and I
would be glad to work with the
representative to find a place to put it
roll the motion is to not allow
representative
Packard uh yes representative
Osborne yes representative
rice
yes Representative Steven
Smith yes representative
sorn yes representative Cushing yes
representative shirtliff yes
representative Weber yes repres
representative Timothy Smith
yes the motion to not allow pass is 9 to
Zer Mr chair thank
you uh I wish I had a complete script in
front of me Mr clerk but I I got whole
bunches of Paper Co could you please yes
sir next yes sir we are now on to house
rules proposals okay and I am going to
uh if if you want to follow along in the
um order that uh was in the agenda we
can start there if that uh that's that's
that's fine thank you all right then we
will start uh with representative
Osborne um and we will start uh
with the
2021 deadlines and I will pull them up
someplace
um representative Osborne
moves amendment to house rule
65 is there a second
a second okay uh
discussion this is um yeah what we
discussed if I'm
correct about two three weeks ago am I
correct Mr Clark this was it is Sir
representative Weber has raised her hand
okay and I think representative kushin
Weber sorry I would defer to
representative Cushing oh go go ahead
representative Weber oh okay uh then I
won't uh my my only concern is that
under January
15th uh one of the second entry is last
day to amend House Rules by majority
vote which is very much in in keeping
with our normal proceedings but I'm
concerned about only about that one line
in case we find that things are
cumbersome on January 6th then we have
to have a an abbrevi ated meeting on
January 6th then we only have the the
15th to allow house members to bring in
um their um amendments to house rules
and because it is such an important
thing and because it is um uh because
we're still sorting out how things are
going to proceed I I wonder if that
could be phrased something more like uh
the first session after January 6th or
the second session after January 6 so
there's a little more leeway there uh
but that's that's my only concern and
I'm I'm not sure how we do that or
whether we we move that date a little
later but knowing that we may not have a
session on the
15th um you know that that's makes it
seem a little worrisome in terms of
giving people an opportunity to make
discussion is there
um any clarification you might have Mr
clerk uh no sir that's um if you if you
choose to move that to another date you
are welcome to I I would only state that
we
um uh we would typically we we've never
not had a date assigned to something um
so to to put in um if you wanted to make
it such that it wasn't a date um I would
suggest that maybe um adding a a a
subsection B um that stated the last day
to amend House Rules by majority vote
would be the session um following the
January 6th session or something along
those lines we you could you could do
that if that uh is what you would like
to do uh I see that representative Weber
has raised her hand again and
representative Tim Smith has raised his
hand okay I would ver oh representative
Weber go ahead I'm sorry I would very
much like to move that we draft it in
draft that change in accordance with the
clerk's recommendation the other thing I
had thought was that perhaps to keep it
cleaner we could have this session
deadlines drafted exactly as they are
and as we would in any other year and
then have a rule somewhere else that we
perhaps in in the section on emergency
rules uh to be adopted later that we add
in a section there that says uh not
withstanding the deadline to amend House
Rules by majority vote contained in rule
65 that uh rules may be amended by
majority vote on on the first section
follow session following January 6th um
that might be a way to do that that
would keep the deadlines clean for the
clerk and also recognize that we are in
an emergency
situation so um that would be my
recommendation Mr chairman I would just
state that uh I appreciate
representative Weber uh recognizing that
I would like to try to keep this as
clean as possible um and and I I think
that the suggestion that she's making um
uh in in terms of of adding that to the
um rule amendment to be adopted later
might be a better proposition I'll hold
off on it till then then thank you uh
questioning no I'm satisfied with this
conversation The Exchange that just had
with the clerk and with representative
Weber that will deal with the concerns
that represented Weber has which I I
share um in another portion of the
amendment so I'm ready to move on this
and and support
it uh I can't see any of the other uh
members do uh anybody else have their
hand up Paul I
can't um no sir is there any further
discussion uh yeah I've had my hand up
oh I'm sorry I I yeah okay I'm sorry I
can't I can't see everybody on my screen
so I don't know who does and doesn't yep
so go ahead yeah
thank you um I'll I Echo the the
concerns about the January 15th deadline
um I air on the side given the current
situation of giving um whoever the
speaker ends up being a little bit more
latitude with the scheduling and and
airing on the side of flexibility with
that and i' you know I'd be in favor of
changing that January 15th to you know
just making it like January 30th or
whatever at the end of the month um just
so that the the new speaker doesn't find
thems in a scramble against a
deadline um you know to to get a rule
change made dealing with something that
that comes up in the next week or two um
it you know I I I know there's been some
public discussion um again that I
haven't been part of you know there
there's been uh a lot of discourse about
how we're going to do our our
legislative sessions and all of that and
I I'm very cognizant that it it is going
to be a challenge um to to come up with
something and make all the logistical
arrangements and I you know
I the the deadlines are kind of cramped
and they always are that's just the way
we do business but the the January 15th
for the the house rules um yeah that
that bothers me i' I'd prefer to give
the speaker a little bit more
flexibility and just bump that to the
end of the month or as representative
Weber had suggested um have another
section drafted somewhere that that
gives a little bit more line item
date I think uh personally if we're
going to amend this and change it I
would rather see a u a finite date uh as
was just suggested maybe January
get too complicated with this so
if Mr Speaker representative rice and
representative Weber had their hands up
representative rice thank you Mr Speaker
so my question
is this is the only opportunity we would
have to amend this if we found that
going forward we were running into time
time issues we couldn't change this
later on
did that make any
sense if if I may answer that um thank
you representative rice so
um it's it's kind of a two-fold question
because the um the amendment that you'll
be discussing later um the emergency
rule Amendment uh does have a provision
in there where the speaker has the
authority to move um some of the dates
around uh with in discussion with the
majority and minority leaders
um the the session regard the section
regarding House Rules by majority vote
um we have typically tied that to and it
typically has not been a session day
it's it's usually a Thursday or Friday
sometime in the middle of the month um
and it and and and specifically we we um
the the more important day in that well
for me anyway is is that that last day
to introduce house bills as well because
uh by by changing that to the Third 30th
that leaves us um sort of at a a a
little bit of a problem in in getting
all bills to committees in in time and
um allows for greater chances of of
endless redrafts that we're very
concerned about um so uh you know that
that's why that those two dates have
typically been assigned
together if I may follow up further
question that that that is my concern I
don't want us to keep pushing stuff out
and end up bogg down and in a crunch and
concern representative Weber has her
hand up Mr chair representative Weber uh
thank you Mr chair um what I would
propose to do which I think does not
actually uh extend things too far but uh
Mr chair my concern is if we did not
have another meeting in January there's
there good reasons that we might not
want to have a new another meeting in
January if we have a date certain for
that the opportunity is lost so what I
would suggest doing is when we get to
the amendment to house rules that deals
with rues 67 emergency rules for covid
pandemic I would suggest that at that
point we add section F that would read
not withstanding the provisions of rule
65 the deadline for amending house rules
shall be extended to the next session
after the January 6th session so there's
only one session more that they can be
raised at and that would preserve our
normal
procedure uh and whenever the next
session is that would be the last
opportunity so you're not extending
things out um you know on on beyond that
it's just that there I want to preserve
one specific protected opportunity for
our members to have a chance to
challenge house rules should they feel
they needed to do
you I don't see any other hands up Mr
Speaker okay
um motion is to adopt
um uh the deadlines as proposed by
representative Osborne and seconded by
representative
rice okay so the motion before us is to
adopt the deadlines as as they are
printed right now am I correct on that
yes sir all
uh uh if there's no other further
discussion clerk will call a roll
representative Packard yes
representative
Osborne yes representative rice yes
Representative Steven Smith yes
representative
sorn yes represent Cushing yes represent
schliff yes represent Weber yes
representative Timothy Smith
yes is adopted N9 to
zero to stop share for a moment and
Amendment Mr chairman we have the
amendment uh to house rules 1057 b64 and
111 changing the references of the uh
2010 Manual of Mason Mason's Manual of
legislative procedure to the 2020
Edition and if I'm correct Mr clerk
that's all this does yes sir that's what
this particular change is and uh
uh would you like to uh a motion please
just a motion motion to adopt Z second
second
okay all right is there any discussion
on this
one question if there be no discussion
clerk will call a all quick question yes
representative Smith um I'm not sure if
it's in if it's in order to ask the
clerk um but it it
do we know when the uh the 2020 version
will be available for for purchase by
the members or is it already available
representative Smith I am glad you asked
that
question the the uh the Mason's manual
2020 Edition is in fact available now um
we do have some copies uh for sale here
at the um at the state house um uh you
can uh purchase one with uh a discount
uh through the visitors Center you can
order direct from ncsl and I am very
pleased to tell you that for the first
time you are able to purchase a digital
version of
Mason's it is available um and uh it is
it is a restricted thing however so you
you will have um uh you will have to
utilize a a login and that sort of thing
uh for it to be uh used so that you know
there are extensive copyrights on it um
but that is uh that is something I'm
announce okay no further discussion the
uh uh read the motion Mr Clerk and so
everybody's clear and call the rooll the
the motion uh Mr chair is to amend house
rules 1057 B and 64d and 111 to make the
reference of Mason's manual legislative
procedure from the 2010 Edition to the
Edition with that representative Packard
yes representative
Osborne yes representative rice yes
Representative Steven Smith yes
representative
sorne yes representative Cushing yes
representative shiff yes representative
Weber yes representative Timothy Smith
yes okay thank you I'm going to turn
this one off the motion is approved I'm
chair and see I still have a huge pile
of papers here Mr clerk what's next um I
um
49 sorry I know this works but boy is it
much nicer to be in person so we are all
page okay Mr chair this is um the
amendment to house rule 49 um and and
just to be clear this amendment was one
that was um adopted Last by
enum it was adopted uh by Voice vote on
the floor of the house this was actually
something that was proposed by myself
and our um uh house committee Services
team um and because of the the the the
way we adopted rules on December 2nd
this um Amendment uh unfortunately um
went by the way in that so uh this
brings that back and it has to do
specifically specifically um which
extends deadlines of study committees
Beyond November first of the second year
um and uh which technically is is both a
violation of rules and statutes so that
is why we asked um two years ago to to
in okay is there any discussion on this
or should we go right to a motion you
need a motion I know represent
representative Smith I see your I see
your
face I see yours too I move to adopt
discussion if there be no discussion uh
the clerk will call the role and a
motion to
accept representative Packard yes
representative
Osborne yes representative rice yes
Representative Steve Smith yes
representative
Sor yes representative Cushing
yes representative Sheriff yes
representative Weber yes representa
Timothy Smith yes the motion passes 19
to z Mr chairman okay here
here pull this one
down uh representative rice uh texted me
um Mr chair and and said that I was
absolutely beaming when I was talking
about the uh Mason
rule I I apologize if I if I was a
little over
giddy like a commercial to me see that
you had such a part in it I can imagine
giddy
okay the emergency rules for the
seven
um represented Smith do you uh uh Steve
Smith you have a thank you Mr chair I
second do we have a second
second oh thank you represent H
discussion uh representative Weber has
chair representa Weber thank you chair
um I would move to amend the proposal to
add a section F that would read as
follows notwithstanding the provisions
of rule
65 the deadline for amending House Rules
shall be extended to the next session
session I'd second the amendment you um
representative Weber um could you I got
to Extended could you fill fill in the
rest of that again for me uh not
withstanding the pro provisions of house
rule 65 the deadline for amending house
rules shall be extended to the next
session after
the January 6th session maybe you want
following the January 6th session but I
I would leave the word smithing of that
to you I just want one session more
after
that all right well we have a motion
right now in front of us uh is there any
discussion and I will say that we
uh try and keep keep things as simple as
possible here if we want to discuss that
point so um the the motion at the at the
moment is to amend the amendment um
right which by the way we can do in this
committee on these things when we're on
the floor we don't amend amendments but
um we can do that in this committee to
to to clarify things so
I I just thought sorry I was just say
representative Weber's hand is up Mr
chair yes go ahead representative Weber
I I just thought it would be cleaner and
simpler for everybody if all of the
emergency rules were adopted as as one
package and if if if the committee is um
okay with this with this one small
Amendment representative Osborne has his
hand up Mr chair okay go ahead
oh you're muted
representative sorry sorry um so in
section c there it talks about uh being
able to uh alter the deadlines in an
effort to thwart uh the
covid-19 um so do we really need uh
another um section here um and then
secondly should it read uh the deadline
for amending House Rules by simple
majority shall be extended
yes representative Weber I think I think
that that is the intention there
correct
um for amending the the deadline for
amending House Rules by a majority vote
by a simple majority by a majority vote
yeah I I would see that as a friendly
Amendment and I would be glad to include
it okay
if my second who is representative
agree
okay does anybody have any discussion
on the amendment to the amendment
I I would just note a question yeah I
would just note that I believe the
language in this is has a slight change
from what it was previously and relative
to the um discussions with a majority
and minority leader and public health
officials but um I'm comfortable I mean
change so the motion before us Mr chair
is to adopt representative Weber's uh
new f into the amendment and then we
would vote on the amendment
separately okay uh and is there any
further discussion if there be no
further discussion then uh clerk will
call a rooll yeah this is for the Weber
Amendment it's for the Weber Amendment
and then we'll go to the amendment
itself thank you sir uh represent
Packard yes representative
Osborne yes representative
rice yes Representative Steven Smith
yes representative
Sor yes representative Cushing yes
representative Sheriff yes
representative Weber yes representative
Timothy
Smith representative Timothy
Smith I'm sorry uh yes okay thank you I
wasn't sure if I lost you so Amendment
uh to the amendment passes 9 to Zer uh
to the
overall uh is there any further
discussion on
uh this particular motion rule
rooll we have a mo we do have the motion
before us am I correct yes yeah yes sir
it was moved by repres reprentative
Smith and second Vice representative
Osborne representative Packard
yes representative
Osborne
yes representative rice yes
Representative Steven Smith
yes representative
Sor yes representative Cushing yes
representative sherff yes representative
Weber yes represent Timothy Smith
yes okay that motion passes N9 to
nothing yes
sir just the next one Mr clerk yes sir
now I believe we've gone through the
Packard
amendments one two three four so we are
now on
here just give me a moment to add him to
our speaking
list we have many partici we have many
attendees today so I'm just uh okay John
GR
okay I'm here Mr clerk yes sir you are
here okay Mr uh chair we have uh
representative Graham on the line to
present um this amendment to house rule
37 go ahead go ahead representative
Graham thank you Mr Speaker members of
the committee for the record
representative John Graham Hillsboro 7
which is the town of Bedford myself and
uh John cluder the representative from
Claremont propose this relatively minor
change to house R 37 in order to
facilitate work in the second year of
the session as you all know the governor
proposes the 10-year Transportation plan
not on the 15th of January in even
numbered years when he does that we then
have to go to the rules committee to get
approval for for uh late Drafting and
introduction of a bill um by putting
this into the same category as we do for
the budget and the capital budget we
would preclude that additional step but
still be able to uh work with the clerk
and with u edmin Ser services to get um
everything done in a timely manner so
that we could look at the bill before
having the second year crossover date
Loom before us as we work on the P plan
it puts it into the same category as I
said as the general budget and the
capital budget um but just in the second
year so I would ask that the committee
approve this relatively minor change to
chairman is there a motion to accept
move to accept all right there a second
pushing yes
representative rice okay is there any
self-explanatory if there be no
discussion then the clerk will call the
r uh thank you Mr shair representative
Packard
Osborne yes thank you uh representative
rice yes
Representative Steven Smith yes
representative
Sor yes representative Cushing yes
representative shirtliff yes
representative Weber yes representative
Timothy Smith
zero okay okay sir we have
representative margorie Smith up next
list
here morning representative
Smith good
morning
um I assume that you would like to go in
order
um that we that was sent along
yesterday um to the chair and the clerk
I would follow uh whatever order you
think is uh most appropriate for the
committee okay I will if I'm correct uh
Mr uh Mr clerk uh he has a number of um
U proposals so why don't we uh go
by numerical order sounds good we'll
um thank you um Mr Clerk and before I
say anything at all um I have
to make one comment to my good friend
and colleague
representative uh Kim rice to say how it
warms my heart to uh to see her and hope
that each day she's better and better
um and I know many people share that
view um in terms of this amendment uh to
house rule
two
um I am and my colleagues are a
very have a very high degree of
commitment both to process um in the
House of Representatives and respect for
the speaker of the House of
Representatives I believe that this
amendment to the rule helps to make
clear how important the speaker is to
determining how we are able to conduct
business both amongst the members the
staff and the public and although it
certainly applies specifically to the
current circumstances that we find
ourselves in I believe it also is
something that applies generally and
reinforces the importance of the speaker
in how we as a house a very large body
functions and I would ask that you
I believe Representative Steve Smith has
a uh motion you have do you have um yeah
thank you Mr chair I move to not
adopt there a
second
discussion yes Mr
chair uh Representative Steve Smith
thank you Mr Speaker I don't disagree
with the sentiment of the rule but you
know I'm a specificity kind of guy and
uh the speaker shall so that's crystal
clear that the state house so I'm
assuming that means the entire complex
is a welcoming inclusive environment for
the members staff and members of the
public in attendance so I guess I want
to know what that looks like in real
life so if a member of the cleaning
staff is not welcoming somehow then the
speaker is the one who gets involved in
the disciplinary action or the labor
dispute so I I agree agree with the the
idea here but I don't think it's
something that can actually
work uh representative rce I can see
your hand up thank you Mr Speaker so my
question is would this open up um the
possibility of litigation against the
speaker if someone were to to follow I
mean we have all that construction what
if they left something out I just see a
lot of different variables and I think
this um could could set the speaker up
for some some bad
things uh representative questionin I
think you had your hand up yeah I I I
think that this is a again consistent
with what representative Smith said I
just think this is a matter in the one
first instance of respecting the speaker
and acknowledging that the powers
inherent with the position include being
responsible for the protection of health
and safety of members uh staff and
members of the public um and I think
it's an appropriate addition to the
house
rules I trust the speaker whomever it
would
be and I want to make clear it's not
going to be the and quite frankly it's
because the speaker needs to be
responsible it's not enough to be you
know a chief of staff or someone else
ultimately um you know ultimately it's
the speaker's responsibility and we know
the keyword is insure it doesn't mean
that he has to or she has to do it uh
you know be micromanaging things it's
just part of the overall responsibility
ities that a speaker
has further
discussion if not I guess I I just want
to say a couple of
things I would hope and pray that any
speaker of either party would do this
automatically that we shouldn't have to
have an in house
roles and uh I
I I agree with it 100% that it is the
the speaker's responsibility to do the
best here she can to make sure that you
know the health and the safety of of
everybody in the building is a a top
priority
and I I just don't believe that he or
she has to
be kind of I I would just say told that
in in a uh in a uh rule I I would hope
that should be
automatic and uh I hope that never
changes if there's no further discussion
clerk call
roll the motion is to not accept it am I
right Mr clerk that is correct sir thank
you representative Packard
yes representative
Osborne yes representative rice
yes Representative Steven Smith yes
representative
sorn yes represent Cushing no represent
shff no represent Weber
no represent Timothy Smith
no motion to not
allow is adopted 5 to
four I guess the next one is Rule
30 yes sir if you give me just a moment
up unless you would prefer I not share
those on the screen I I just thought
that that might helpful and all yes I
think that's helpful Mr clerk yeah I
think that's I say I've got all this
kind of paper was just deliver it to me
this morning and it I just haven't had a
chance to put it all together so that's
repres um thank you very much um Mr
chair um before um I continue I do have
one question if we were in
person um as someone who presented um an
amendment um I might have had an
opportunity to
respond and um while I signaled raay
hand um I guess that didn't count and I
just want to say as to the
last um Amendment there was nothing in
that
Amendment uh that assumed that the
speaker would not want to do this the
language in that amendment was to ensure
that no one would challenge the speaker
who exercised his or her authority
to keep the environment safe and that I
would have added if I had been allowed
to say anything thing as to amending uh
house rule 30 um M uh we know that we
have
[Music]
um am I on again you are I thank you um
um this adds just it shall be the
further duty of the committee on
legislative Administration to review the
existing statutory and study committees
to ensure that all committees are still
necessary for the work of the house we
have had over the years any number of um
cumbersome structures um relating to our
love of creating statutory and study
committees and then having them continue
to exist long after they are
useful this is a way to give one of our
statutory
committees um clear authority to review
the other statutory and study committees
and to to ensure that their time has not
come and gone um we believe that this is
a way to increase the
efficiency and um the
uh the efficiency of of the house and um
to increase the relevance of the work
that we ask members of the house to do
and I would urge you to increase the
powers of the committee on legislative
language um Mr chair representative
Weber has her hand up for question uh
well first let's uh see if we can get a
motion and then we can go into the
discussion Mr Sher if I may I I think um
to address representative Smith's uh
concern from before uh typically um you
would you would normally have questions
um of the of the proposer uh and then um
you can you can certainly have your
motion following
that um and I apologize to uh
representative Smith uh what I'm seeing
on my screen is just a still picture of
you and uh if I is is not my intention
whatsoever to deny anybody uh to speak
to their Amendment and not takes
questions so I apologize for that thank
you Mr chair and there's no need to
apologize I don't have any choice I
believe in what you see and the picture
is probably better than what I look like
anyway it's a wonderful picture
uh so are there uh questions for uh yes
represent Weber has her hand up uh
okay Mr chair I had my hand up to make a
motion if that was
acceptable well yes yeah I would move
that we accept this language and I would
like to speak to my motion okay
second um thank you I I just having been
involved in several rounds when we had
to file
legislation and had a five or 10e
buildup of committees some of which were
useful some of which were not useful it
just seems to me to be very helpful if
legislative Administration as a
committee has the authority to go ahead
and take a look at these at whatever
time they think is is most um is most
useful
um and by putting it in here they can do
exactly the same thing that they do with
other issues they can send it to a
subcommittee it can either go back to
allege admin or come straight to the
house but I think it's a very efficient
way and and saves us a couple of steps
and maybe focuses the mind a little more
on making sure that we police all of
those committees and and get rid of the
ones we're not needing in a timely
fashion because it's a huge drain on
staff time and uh it's a huge um it's it
it will be a huge uh issue for your
Deputy speaker in terms of appointing
people to committees which may then not
meet so um uh I'm I'm pleased to make a
motion to
accept well when I looked at this
representative Weber the other day um I
we were looking at so much stuff I
didn't really have a chance to really
look at it closely um having done those
appointments for twice um even both in
the majority and the minority it is a
daunting task because especially we had
such a hard time finding people to fill
the
seats um I actually like this uh if I
remember
correctly uh under speaker narelli I
think she did something like this a
number of years ago that they took a
close look at the um statutory and
commissions and cut some of them down
that weren't meeting or
unnecessary so I I I think this is a um
not a bad idea to uh to add on to the
policies and it could cut down quite a
bit on on as you say staff time and
having committees that don't meet except
for once every four or five years and uh
really don't accomplish anything
representative rice has her hand up Mr
representative rice yes thank you very
much so my my only question is um I'm
having a hard time reading it because
it's small but would this go in front of
um like would there be public testimony
people be able to testify against like
them wanting to get rid of a certain
committee or is this just going to be
like a unilateral they can do what they
want without input from the public
I would hope representative Smith and
I'll ask the clerk to clarify this that
if we're going to put this in there that
it would be the duty of the legislative
Administration committee to bring uh a
particular commission or statutory
committee up and actually bring people
in to uh testify in favor or against
that so that uh there could be
clarification as to what the committee
does when it meets how often it meets
meets if it meets and what any of the uh
reports that were supposed to be
submitted usually in November to the uh
speaker the Senate President and the
governor so um and I I will refer to the
clerk that if does this do what um I
believe it should do so so um Mr chair
to answer your question um any any type
of change would require legislation uh
so so this
this would empower the committee um to
do their work and bring in legislation
uh to to get rid of or you know enhance
or elongate the the the time of the
committee or
commission okay
now we can do that now anyways can't
we yes um to to an extent uh this you
know by having by having this in here uh
it does sort of empower the committee to
to take that uh on as as as a task um
you know you referenced uh speaker
narelli back in in
2010 uh we did have uh we actually
called it the committee on committees um
and it was a creation by legislation uh
that looked at all of these these
various things and made several
recommendations um and and filed
legislation uh based on their work uh to
to get rid of some of these things and
also to um reorganize and that sort of
thing as
well representative um Cushing has his
hand up and representative Weber did as
well uh representative Cushing yeah I
when I looked at this I kind of think of
it the same way um we assigned to the
policy committee that had jurisdiction
over a particular area to take a look at
the performance audits that the LBA did
so that um you know someone had the
responsibility to take a look at uh you
know a specific report and perhaps
proposed legislation perhaps not but at
least have someone somebody who's who's
who is responsible for acting upon this
work that was done I think it makes
sense just to have legislative
Administration to have as its
responsibility to you know be alert find
out if there are any you know Phantom
study Phantom study committees out there
things that aren't functioning that
aren't working that we just need to we
should just be able to clean it up as
opposed to having every five years uh
commit appoint and pass the statute to
have a new other Committee of committees
obsolete representative Weber has minut
first okay where sener Weber and I would
I would just add that if if we put the
permission in here then the committee on
committees could have a subcommittee a
standing subcommittee if they wanted or
an ad hoc committee which then would all
to in order to meet because it's an
official house committee anytime that
subcommittee met there would have to be
notice and uh uh public attendance uh to
to um with respect to their discussions
a and I just think it focuses the mind
to have it in there as a duty um and and
allows some leeway for uh the way to
deal with it as the clerk says any
ultimate resolution has to come by
Statute so um it would all have the
proper um public input but it might be
useful to be able to get things resolved
somewhat informally first and then draft
a statute afterwards that is an Omnibus
statute that takes care of all the
things that have been resolved thank
you representative Tim Smith has his
hand up all right representative Tim
Smith
thank you um I I just want to say that
as somebody who has been appointed to a
number of these Phantom committies over
the years um that had membership but no
business uh didn't didn't meet didn't
produce reports at least not that anyone
ever made me aware of um you know I I
asked the question several times over my
my tenure in the legislature like why am
I on this weird committee that doesn't
do anything in some cases I didn't even
find out out for months um that I was
appointed to this committee uh
specifically because it's it's a phantom
committee left over from you know
legislation seven years ago that no
longer serves a function um and no one
could tell me um what I was supposed to
do or like who had the responsibility to
review that situation um and I I really
strongly support the idea of you know
adding this line item to the
responsibilities of legis ative
Administration as being the the people
with that responsibility so that um you
know a member of the the house who finds
thems in a similar situation um at least
has a particular place to go um to to
provide feedback or seek information
rather than just blindly send emails to
the House and Senate staff and hope that
somebody can give them something um I I
think that this would be an extremely
posit POS clarifying measure if nothing
else um for for members of our body who
who finds confused wondering why they're
they're on the the committee to stutter
uh you know the committee to stutter
study water filtration patterns in 2012
and it it's now going to be 2021 and
that further
discussion Representative Steve Smith
has his hand up Representative Steve
Smith thank you Mr chair um so you
probably won't be surprised to here I
couldn't disagree more I I don't think
legi admin can do this uh a few years
ago I was appointed to a couple of
commissions and actually was surprised
to find out that by Statute I was the
chair of one and I'd never heard of
either of them so I looked them up and I
was able to find a little information on
one and zero on the other looking at the
general Court website there had never
been any meetings there had never been
any
reports so I filed bills to repeal both
of them and one case crickets and the
other one my phone started ringing uh
staff from the Department of Safety the
New Hampshire Motor Transport
Association uh whoever it is that's in
charge of the taxes turns out this
commission was actually meeting was
doing good work and it was just
invisible for some reason it was a
pretty arduous process to figure out
that one of them the duties some of the
duties should be transferred to that and
it requires a high level of subject
matter expertise I would vote against
this and direct ask whoever the next
speaker is to make this the job of each
committee chair rather than one house
committee who may never have heard of
either of them and not know who the
specific contacts were I mean uh just
think if my phone had not rang and we
ended up repealing a commission that was
doing good work was just having
reporting problems and to fix that it
required um a slight tweak to the
membership to allow getting it on their
meetings onto the house calendar um so I
totally agree with doing this and Mr
chair you've heard me shake the cage
before that this is something we should
be focusing on but I disagree that the
committee on legislative Administration
is the committee to do
okay the motion is
to accept rule amendment to rule 30 am I
correct Mr clerk yes sir uh there there
be no further
discussion uh the clerk will call a
roll represent Packard uh
no represent
Osbourne
No representative rice no Representative
Steven Smith no
representative
Sor no representative Cushing
yes representative schliff
yes representative Weber yes
representative Timothy Smith
yes the motion to accept fails 5 to
four move on to the
next another
correct um you just give me a second
here
sorry
yes uh representative uh Smith may I ask
you a question um the uh we have two
rules to rule 60 uh two amendments to
rule
63 um one of them pertains to weapons
one pertains to alcohol is there an
order in which you'd like to
proceed um I am uh at your uh Mercy um
Mr clerk you and the chair are in charge
and I would just like to mention yet
again that it would have been nice if I
could have answered some of the
questions on the
previous um
uh uh proposal I did press raise hand
but I guess raising hand for me doesn't
count but you're in charge so you tell
me how to
proceed so as I was trying to explain
earlier representative Smith and this is
U normally what happens in rules is a
member makes their proposal uh and
members ask their questions of the the
proposer uh and at that point um when
the when a uh a motion is made
essentially the the committee is in exec
session and does not take input um thank
you very
much um that being said um
if if you have a preference uh that no
you you
you I follow your direction all right
then we'll we'll we'll go alphabetical
just because so let's do
that okay we'll start with the alcohol
[Music]
does everyone see the
amendment
yes uh you may rep present it represent
Smith thank you very much um Mr chair um
the only change in uh house rule 63 is
to add a sentence at the
end sometimes it is true that we um are
fighting the last war
and we figure out what to do based on
what happened before not knowing if it's
going to happen again uh and there's no
question that this falls into that
category up until um recent
events uh we would not have thought
there was any need to clarify what
appropriate decorum would be in the
house of repres Representatives but now
we all know that it is necessary to be
specific about certain behaviors that
are clearly not in the do not respect
the safety or the decorum or appropriate
behavior of members of the house and
because of that perhaps it's belt and
suspenders perhaps not but um I would
propose that we add this language so
that people would not be
confused and think that perhaps it would
be appropriate to behave in this way
that among other things damages the
you repes representative sh uh yeah
representative Sher I thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I would move the
acceptance of this
amendment representative Weber seconds
if I could just speak briefly to my
motion Mr Speaker you may thank you Mr
Speaker in the last session of the house
one of the saddest
days that we met was the day that we
found that a dozen cans of empty beer
were found behind one particular section
of the house and I learned that this
wasn't the first occasion that members
had Drank In The House
chamber uh this was at least the second
second time they had done something so
soft moric as to drink alcohol in the
chamber of the New Hampshire House of
Representatives Mr chair Mr chairman
like
yourself um I have great respect for the
institution of the New Hampshire house
and especially the chamber in which we
meet no matter where the legislature
meets that is our house chamber and to
have members of the New Hampshire house
act with less maturity than a fourth
grade class visiting the state house
just simply amazes me if they think when
their constituents elect them to serve
in the house chamber it's the equivalent
of going to a Red Sox game they're in
the wrong body and I would urge the
members of this committee to pass this
amendment so that never again will
anybody disgrace in New Hampshire house
by thinking they can drink alcohol in
the body in the people's house where
we're passing legislation on behalf of
the people we serve thank you Mr
discussion see any hands up Mr chair oh
representative Osborne has raised his
hand represent
re really uh I really don't want to get
dragged into the gutter
today and I I can't uh I can't believe
that we're still pretending to be
outraged over this
situation uh we no no member meant
anything
disrespectful on that
day uh as far as I
know members believed that during
lunchtime that that building we were in
ceased to be the house and instead
became a Cafeteria Restaurant whatever
you want to call it um you know members
had food on the floor uh that they were
eating which we don't normally do in the
house
chamber number of behaviors occurring
during that time period that we do not
do in the house chamber this rule is
unnecessary and uh I think it is uh it
is best for all of us to be able to get
through these times that we are in if we
can let this go and uh and take care of
the people's
Privilege I will allow a little bit of
attitude
I mean I only asked Mr chair because the
member had just said it's too late for
people to be to still pretend to be
outraged there's no pretense in my
outrage at what happened that day it's
not pretend it's not trying to be
political I'm not attacking any
political party or any two individuals
who I think were taking part in that the
fact that no matter what we may be
having our lunches there because of the
Health crisis but to for someone to come
in and bring alcohol in uh denigrates
the body in which I am so proud like you
you further discussion representative
Osborne all may I respond I I I will
respond to apologize for
um I get
um insinuating a a motive or putting
putting thoughts in uh the
representative's head that uh it's not
my place to put there I thank the
member representative Tim Smith has his
hand up Sir uh representative Tim
Smith um thank you um I i' just say that
this amendment and others like it um I
see this as empowering the Speaker of
the House you know we um we find
ourselves in situations sometimes where
somebody does something
and there's no
there's no clear Authority for them to
be held accountable for it um and you
know I I'll I'll say this as someone who
has sat on a legislative disciplinary
hearing um you know in recent memory the
the question comes up sometimes it's
like okay this person did something that
you know denigrated the house or or was
otherwise unacceptable um but was it
actually against the rules and if not we
don't have any Authority or the speaker
wouldn't even have any authority to you
know to do to discipline them or hold
them accountable or or even really just
have a a Stern sort of a discussion with
them asking them to you know cut the
nonsense um this would provide a grounds
for such action you know if if we find
somebody uh drinking alcohol or or using
illegal substances or something in the
chamber um as it stands right now it
would be very difficult for for for the
house leadership to to Really find a
justification um to even just ask that
member to stop um and I I I see this
entirely as empowering the speaker of
the house and I I share the sentiments
of Representative shirtliff um and
representative Smith who presented it I
think it's unfortunate that this is uh
necessary but it is reactionary and it
is necessary um so that's all I would
add
representative Osborne's hands up as his
Representative Steve Smiths okay uh
representative Osborne oh he's waving
off oh he's waving off Representative
Steve
Smith thank you Mr chair and this may
make you smile a little but I remember
the Representative Steve Smith of say I
don't know six to eight years
ago you'll know that I'm an authority
that the speaker staff can they've got a
lot things they can do to troublemakers
and I experienced some of that I'm
pretty sure I experienced some of it
from you as well Mr chair and I have
full confidence in the speaker's office
to have the ability to deal with
situations as they arise even if they're
not covered in a specific house rule but
it's Behavior that's um
clearly well I don't I don't want to
beat myself up too bad since I was the
Troublemaker back then but I have full
full confidence in your ability to deal
with situations that come up without
this
rule I I I agree
um having
been involved in the speaker's office
for four
years I can't count the number of
circumstances where a member was brought
in because of some kind of activity or
something of that nature that they they
partic participated in and um they were
brought in and and
and talked to uh and and I'm sure uh
speaker Sheriff you know had to do the
same thing so I
I I agree that I I really believe that
the speaker has the ability to bring
anybody in at any time and speak to them
about an activity that they deem to be
unsatisfactory and I I don't think we
need to continually put these type of
things into the rules so I will be
this there's no further further
questions or I'm it discussion
representative Cushing has his hand
representative King yeah you know I I
think it's important not just that the
the speaker uh on a Case by case BAS
can call someone out and and and tell
them that drinking in the in the house
Chambers is is not a good idea I think
it's important that the house itself as
a body that we take a position and put
it in our rules that nobody should be
drinking or using illegal substance in
rep's hall or in in the chamber I think
it's a matter of the the kind of the
respect and honor of the house itself
that we take this position and I will be
supporting it
I just got to
um to say that um and I I don't know of
this but um I don't know the whole
circumstances of what happened at
UNH uh I wasn't involved to them I
didn't see anything happen um so I'm not
going to comment on what happened or
didn't happen but having been a member
of the House for 30 years I don't ever
remember
and I could be wrong and just not been
informed of it of any of these type of
circumstances ha happening in our house
chamber at the state
house and I'm not sure we need
to put different kind of rules in place
for one
incident or two incidences that happen
in unusual
circumstances so uh again I I respect
what you're saying as far as you don't
want it happening I don't want it
happening either but I do believe the
speaker already has that authority to to
uh attend to it if something does
unnecessary there be no
further
[Music]
um unless representative marjerie Smith
has something as we can't see her hand
so I I I want to make sure that uh if
she uh wishes to uh say something that
she has the ability to do that even
though we can't see her
hand if that be the case then the clerk
will call her
all the motion is uh to accept the
amendment representative Packard
no representative
Osborne no representative rice
no Representative Steven Smith no
Representative
sorn no representative Cushing yes
representative schliff yes
representative Weber yes representative
Timothy Smith
yes the motion fails five to
four give me just a moment I will pull
um
screen uh representative Smith majie
Smith thank you very much Mr chairman
with three Smiths on the call it's a
little complicated isn't it only one
Packard though
um when in the 2006
election um the Earth Shook and uh
Democrats uh were in the majority in the
New Hampshire
house um everyone including all the
Democrats were quite
shocked and we came in with nobody
having had any training or experience um
in terms of being chairs or vice chairs
or anything like that but we did have
rules
and when the Democrats achieved the
majority we respected to the to the
greatest possible extent the rules that
existed in the house and the rules that
existed in the house included
language that um limited
uh
weapons in the chamber that was the long
established
Republican position and it was a
position that
continued until there was a slight break
in the action and then continued
again and now we're at a point when this
language is not in the rules as they
were adopted a few weeks ago at the
field in front of um the whittimore
center
this proposes to bring back into the
rules language which has long been
included um
under overwhelmingly Republican and
sometimes three times
Democratic um uh control and it is I
Believe essential to the well being of
the house and to the safety of the
members of the house and uh it is
responsible and it is historically
consistent with what the house has done
over the years and I ask that
you um accept this amendment to house
[Music]
okay representative rice has her hand up
representative
rice you're muted
representative I'm sorry I move no on
accepting this
discussion or questions for
representative uh majy Smith uh
representative rice shirtliff and
Timothy Smith okay representative
rice thank you Mr chairman um I again I
am a full believer that I should be able
to protect myself no matter where I'm at
and especially in these highly political
times where people are very angry and so
I'm not going to be a Sitting
Duck that's
all representative is it shortliffe next
y representative shift thank you Mr
chair Mr chair I uh speak in opposition
to the motion not to accept this
I remember when we first voted in the
house to allow firearms and I had we had
a dear old state representative from
Manchester whose name I won't mention
but uh he was not in the best of health
and I remember him coming over to tell
me don't worry Steve if anything happens
in the house I've got my gun with me
today and I thought to myself Mr chair
heaven forbid something should happen
because you never know who he might hit
when he starts firing that gun because
of his ill
health we know that many members of the
House carry weapons I don't know how
many of them have gone had any training
whatsoever we've had incidents in the in
the in the legislature where house
members have dropped their weapons I sat
in a committee room next to a person who
whose weapon fell out of their shoulder
holster and bounced on the ground in the
criminal justice committee um
we've had problems we had members in
another Committee just a couple years
ago same thing uh her weapon fell out of
her purse um there is no training there
is no requirement and I always think Mr
chair that uh we are the House of
Representatives we're there to make the
laws for the people of New Hampshire but
we also serve as a
classroom and I I worry about those
fourth grade ators in the visitors
Gallery they should not be in an
environment where anybody can be
carrying a a firearm including the
person sitting next to him in the
visitor center it just is not
appropriate in the New Hampshire house
uh we have an excellent security between
our Capitol Police our doorkeepers in
the New Hampshire State Police um I feel
perfectly secure the New Hampshire house
chamber is not a place for firearms
thank you Mr
chair uh representative Tim Smith is
next I
believe thank you Mr chairman um you
know i' I'd point out that as a as a
society we identify there are certain
places uh out in
society um
where it's better for the public good to
have
facilities security
handle security Arrangements rather than
just leave it to you know individual
people to to carry a gun or whatever for
personal
protection um jails courtrooms the White
House so on and so
on I think that the New Hampshire house
you know the legislative
chamber um is correct in being one of
those places or has for a very long time
been correct in being one of those
places that
that empowers and tasks uh the
facilities staff with the security
Arrangements rather than just leaving it
up to individuals and the reason we do
that I feel compelled to again remind
the members the reason we do that is not
because of some philosophical point or
some ideological position on the Second
Amendment or anything like that it is
entirely a practical consider ation the
reason that the rule was originally put
into place back in the early
1970s by Speaker of the House Marshall
cobbley was because a member of the
House brought a gun into the chamber and
threatened to shoot him because he was
the member was unhappy about their
seating
assignment that's not my opinion or
interpretation it's the historical
record as as a matter of fact in the
late speaker koby's political Memoir
which I happen to have a copy of called
we ain't making sausage here he
dedicates an entire chapter chapter 37
entitled he's going to shoot you he
dedicates that entire chapter to
describing the incident in detail and
the Mad scramble that took place after
the fact to try and find some Authority
in the rules or statute or some
something to disarm this member in the
house who was armed and threatening
violence against the speaker of the
house it strikes me as the height of
irresponsibility that we would Prelude
this from the house rules and remove
that
Authority um to respond to a similar
situation in kind in the unthinkable
circumstance that it were to happen
again and reminding everyone it's not a
philosophical point it has happened once
and I
I I hope we don't find ourselves
regretting removing this section from
the
discussion Representative Steve Smith
has his hand up and
represent uh Representative Steve Smith
thank you Mr chair I'd only point out
that I don't know what time period that
happened but if that were to happen now
there are a variety of felonies so that
there actually is a statutory method of
dealing with it if I would to say I'm
unhappy with my assignment pull out a
gun and threaten to shoot you about it
there's criminal menacing criminal
threatening I mean there are a variety
of things that can be used to deal with
it so um perhaps back in that time
period the only way to deal with it was
a house rule but that's just not the
case
Osborne yeah I just uh wanted to say
that
uh I I wish we could uh come up with a
rule that uh we could all agree on that
would not keep us in this situation of
flip-flopping every time that
the um you know the majority shifts um I
don't know if that's possible um you
know this obviously is not the way of
doing it um so I I hope someone comes up
someday uh further questions or
discussion representative Cushing has
his hand
up okay R cushion just briefly I you
know I Echo the words uh
of former speaker sherff and Tim Smith
representative Smith um on about this
issue and I I remember I I knew Marshall
Coby I remember he was the first Speaker
I ever met um and um the the words that
he spoke of in his in his book are
really are relevant to today um and the
there were existing back in the 70s
those statutory requirements this is
about how we operate in the chamber and
I think um this is an appropriate rule
I wasn't going to say anything on this
but I I I I feel compelled I have to um
and I'm sure that
um um former speaker shli probably had
the same things happen to him just in
the past week alone since the loss of
our uh colleague representative hinch
speaker
hinch I have had
two threatening emails sent to me over
different issues and I've only been here
my acting speaker for what a week and a
half now but I've had two violent active
emails sent to
me I
wish
that both
sides our parties could
contain the absolute
fanatics on both sides of our
parties
uh if anything it would make me want to
start carrying a weapon at this point
because I don't know who is going to
come after me and how they're going to
come after me so I
I I I I I'm I'm concerned
about in many cases how we're moving
forward and I I for one will never ever
agree to deny a member the right to
protect himself or a person or a citizen
of this state for that reason I I'm
might par you know Mr Speaker I I I
stand with you and I condemn the kind of
you know threats and attacks that any of
us have to experience because of our
public service and I just want to I say
that and sometimes it's not about
members of our of either one of our
parties that there were just forces out
there who would not fit into any
particular party who do uh you know
promote violence um and are opposed to
civil discourse but I I I I I condemn
what happened to you I I I I I believe
you're right representative kushen um
they probably don't belong to any one of
the parties and uh uh but the fact that
the matter is uh we're in a strange time
right now and
um I really um am concerned about you
know the safety of not only our house
citizens there be no further discussion
if there no further
discussion clerk will call a role which
I believe is to not accept it if I'm
remember that's correct
sir motion is to not representative
Packard yes representative
Osborne yes representative rice yes
Representative Steven Smith yes no wait
it was yeah I'm sorry to not accept to
not accept that's what I'm voting
for representative
Sor yes representative Cushing no
representative sherli
no representative Weber
no representative Timothy Smith
no motion to not accept passes the
amendment fails okay we go off to the
next Amendment
please what next Mr Clark is it uh we
have
u67 yes sir
okay we ALS oh you're going to put it up
sir and it should be on your screen sir
thank you very much uh representative
marjerie
Smith thank you um Mr chair
um I'm beaten but not unbowed
and I now present to
you um an amendment to add rule
67 um which acknowledges the reality of
the world in which we live and
acknowledges I hope that we would like
to make life better for legislators
legislative officers and staff and
therefore this just proposed
sexual harassment training as determined
by the
speaker aimed at preventing sexual
harassment it's very simple there's
nothing else in there but its importance
is profound we have again and again um
examples of uh sexual harassment perhaps
deliberate perhaps not
deliberate
um and I would ask you to support adding
this
motion M representative Cushing has his
hand up question I move out to
pass to accept
yes and
I represent
Weber is that correct
yes and if I might um I might speak yes
we're open for discussion you know you
know as we know unfortunately there is a
history of uh sexual harassment that has
taken place
within the legislature itself I know
that you know several years ago perhaps
a decade or more ago was an instance
where a member of the staff was
subjected to unwanted sexual advances by
a legislator um that continued um there
is just by definition an asymmetrical
power relationship between a legislator
and a staff person um and sometimes um
we need to we actually need to all work
and to confront um this kind of sexual
harassment that is all too pervasive um
in our society but as legislators we
should be setting the example we need to
set the example on how we relate to each
other and how we relate to our staff and
how we relate to members of the public I
I will note that the case I ear referred
to resulted in a lawsuit that cost the
legislature um in the state of New
Hampshire substantial amount of money um
and this is again the the requirement
that there be sexual harassment
prevention training was in the rules uh
prior during the prior session I think
it's a a good policy we all benefit from
amendment further discussion
representative Tim Smith has his hand up
representative Smith thank you um so I
would just point out that when
the motion was made um last month on
organization day um that had the the net
effect of removing this from the rules
um one of the issues raised uh was that
the previous language required inperson
attendance
um I I would just remind the members
that this new drafted language remedies
that um and it just says uh Education
and Training as determined by the
speaker um that that gives an enormous
amount of leeway in terms of the form
and delivery
um frankly a memo sent out could
probably satisfy the requirements of
this um but I I think purely you know if
for no other reason than as a legal
measure
for the house uh and the the speaker to
be able to say that our members have
been trained accordingly um is certainly
an appropriate thing to have
happen then Osborne has his hand up sen
wbor yes thank you uh so I'll say the
same thing about this as the as the
other proposals that we have for
training and that is that uh TR training
does not belong in House Rules
that
um uh the best way to get people to uh
uh attend training that you want them to
do is to convince them that they should
not not to force them to and I think
you'll have a much uh much higher level
of attendance uh if we are to offer
these trainings on a voluntary basis and
uh to the representative Smith uh any of
these trainings uh that you set up uh I
will commit to attend and uh hear what
discussion I don't see any hands up Mr
chairman there be no further discussion
uh the motion is
to I'm sorry what is the motion motion
is to accept the motion is to accept
thank you uh if there be no further
discussion the clerk will call a
roll representative beard
no representative
Osborne no representative rice no
Representative Steven Smith no
representative
Sor no representative Cushing yes
representative shirtliff yes
representative Weber yes representative
Timothy Smith
yes motion to accept fails five to four
now should be appearing on your
uh representative marjerie Smith uh
presented please thank you very much Mr
chair I could in the interests of people
getting exhausted ask to remove this um
and some subsequent amendments but I
will not do that because I believe this
and those that have preceded it and will
follow are important additions and I
would rest my case um that we need to
have um training and and
education um to prevent the creation of
a hostile work environment based on
actions that have gone on again and
again and again it is important that as
representative Osborne says that we find
a way to encourage people to do this but
we
found that
without specific rules nobody pays
attention to elements of the environment
that we create that we nurture in the
legislature and therefore I think it is
in keeping with representative Osborne's
comments that we include this language
to encourage and make clear that members
of the legislature
staff um officers should have a much
better idea of what a hostile work
environment is not for any individual
but for every individual because actions
which for one of us might seem to be
perfectly innocent and harmless cause
pain for others and all of us can
benefit from being exposed to some
different ways of viewing how we behave
ourselves and how we behave with
reference to others I ask for you to
okay
uh somebody want to make a make a motion
sentive
Weber I will move that we accept house
rule 68 the amendment rule 68 is there a
second second second sh
discussion represent Cushing has his
hand
up thank you Mr Mr Speaker I just will
say that I think that the state house
that the House of Representatives should
be a safe space for all and that by
adopting this uh Amendment we'll take a
step forward to ensuring that that is
the
discussion a quick note it looks like
the the speaker um the house Clerk's on
the phone but I have my hand up if I can
be recognized okay I see sorry
representativ go
ahead um I'd just say similar to the
last one um I I think it you know in the
unfortunate possible situation where uh
an employee of the house were to you
know experience a hostile work
environment and file a lawsuit against
the House of
Representatives um it it would probably
be advantageous for The house's legal
council to be able to say um in terms of
you know protecting the liability of the
house as an
institution um for the house Council to
be able to say that legislators did
receive this training um rather than
just leave it up to Hope and good luck
um that the you know that everyone just
decided to attend of their own free will
and their own just good nature um I I
think I mean I I agree with what
representative Osborne had said earlier
um that you know it is far preferable
just as a motivational tool in in a
general abstract concept
um to get people to want to do the right
thing um but in a situation like this
where there are like potential legal
consequences and lawsuit settlements at
stake um I I'm sorry we just don't live
in that world yet and I wish that we did
um I I think this is very important just
to protect the
institution further
discussion Representative Steven Smith
has his hand up okay Representative
Steven Smith
thank you Mr chair look I I agree that
this is training that legislators should
get I'm actually a little on the fence
about legislative staff if that should
come from someplace else or not but the
bottom line is when you do this through
house rules what happened last time was
we began with a great big fight about
whether or not this belongs in house
rules I don't even know if we ever got
to the part of the conversation where we
talked about whether the training was a
good idea so I'm going to vote against
this but I'm also going to give you
might pledge that if anybody would like
me to work on it or I'm in a position to
do so I'll put the together the training
together and try to persuade people to
attend it or just slip it into an
orientation training maybe they won't
even know what happen so there are a lot
of ways to do this without deliberately
setting up a fight and I I know
representativ Marjorie Smith has really
good intentions in doing this but I
still think that's what's going to
happen we're going to talk about the
fight not the topic so that's why can't
support it represent Weber has her hand
up representative Weber thank you Mr
chair and um uh with representative
Osborne sentiment on some of the other
issues I will just say I wish we could
find a way of making it clear that this
needs to happen because it's a
requirement of every other
Workforce in the
State uh that they have both all of
these kinds of trainings and I have
found the ones that we've had for the
State House immeasurably useful even
though I attend them regularly year
after year I always learn something new
about ways of relating people and I
found that they generated very good
conversations uh among among
Representatives but I just want to say
this I understand that there would be a
huge fight about it and with
representative Osborne I don't want to
spend a lot of time on that but it seems
bizarre to me that we spend so much
energy fighting something which is a
requirement for virtually every other
workplace in the state of New Hampshire
discussion don't see any Mr
chair I'm gonna um if there be no
further discussion I'll uh I'll uh ask
the clerk to call the roll the motion is
to accept the motion is to accept Okay
representative Packard
no representative
Osborne no representative rice no
Representative Steven Smith no
Representative
sbor no representative Cushing yes
representative sherff yes representative
Smith oh sorry I thought I was muted um
yes okay the motion to accept fails five
to
four we'll move on to the next point of
order if I might yes represent question
yeah I mean I I I know how the vote
would come out I I I realized that in
the last motion and L Mo this in the
last um proposed amendment in this at
least they were the Motions to not
accept failed um and it's logical that
what would be substitute with a motion
to um you know that a motion not to
accept we don't have to do anything to
confirm another way we just have it even
though a motion to pass fails we don't
have to take an affirmative step to um
I think we're on to rule 69 if I'm
yes uh reput Cent ative majie Smith
please thank you um Mr chairman
um I think Mr chairman that all I have
to say about this is I rest my
case I believe that what has transpired
in the
last hour or two or it seems like 102
hours but I know it hasn't been um we
have had vote after vote after
vote that was based not on the merits of
The
Proposal I believe but on
unconscious bias on the part of
members of the committee we look at
something we see where it's coming from
and we just assume that is something
that we really aren't interested in or
we aren't willing to support and we
don't stop to think about what we are
doing is affecting the quality of the
lives of other people this is one more
proposal for training that I believe is
essential for legislators and
legislative office and legislative staff
to be exposed to what unconscious bias
really means and how when we think we're
doing something
that's right when we're really offending
the person who was the recipient of our
comments it's not necessarily done
deliberately it's not done with any
negative um intentions but nonetheless
we hurt and we damage other people I
believe it is important for legislators
to be exposed to Education and Training
about a whole
category of behaviors that govern our
everyday um actions in the house and
unconscious bias training is in some
ways perhaps more important than the
others that have gone before and been
defeated
because it is unconscious it's not that
we say oh well we believe everybody
should have a weapon therefore we'll be
opposed to anything that governs um how
weapons are handled um we understand you
need a driver's license to drive but you
shouldn't necessarily need a license to
do XY or z um
and I know I'm I'm Meandering I'm
Meandering I guess because I'm so
frustrated but we don't know what we
don't know and unconscious biased
training is an attempt to address that
so that we can say oh I had no idea that
I was offending you by doing what I
routinely do now one would hope you
would think first about whether you're
demonstrating bias and I urge you to
69 to include unconscious biased
motion representative Cushing has his
hand up representative Cushing thank you
Mr Speaker I move I move that we ought
to accept this amendment and I like to
speak to that
second yeah you know briefly I think the
the question about unconscious bi bias
is particularly important to people of
color who are within our institutions
who operate it um I think we recognize
that the you know the majority of the
legislature is of um you know a a a
European uh background and perspective
or American European and what we don't
do very well is deal with kind of the
the the everyday acts of of racism that
are that do damage to people of color
within the legislature and people of
color throughout the state of New
Hampshire I think this is a way that we
can take an affirmative steps to make
our uh our our legislature our state a
more welcoming um and inclusive place I
note that just earlier this year the New
Hampshire Supreme Court
um recognized the existence of
unconscious bias um in a in a kind of a
landmark case and really put it upon the
state and and in in the institutions to
try to take uh affirmative steps to U
remediate the unconscious bias and I
think that's that's what will take place
when we adopt this rule thank
discussion pres stepen Smith has his
hand
repr St
Smith thank you Mr chair um I'll take a
breath I I find it ironic that the
motivation for the votes that I've cast
today were assumed by the sponsor of
this uh amendment to house
rules I have not lied to you today I
have not been insincere and my
objections to many of the amendments
were just how they were simply the fact
I don't know how to make that that thing
sto ringing I apologize there my son
took care of it so um I think it's a
better house rule that we're never
supposed to assume motivation or
anything but simply the fact that came
before us and the Very fact that we're
even talking about this to me is a
violation of that rule which should be
one that's like sacred
so this is a box we shouldn't open if
people want this training fine but think
about how it was presented Ed with an
assumption about why each of us voted
the way we have today um even if I
agreed with the concept based on that I
couldn't possibly vote for this and I
won't representative cushion yeah just
um to to representer Smith I I want to
speak that I do not presume that you
have at any time time today acted in a
manner other than out of your sincere
beliefs and so just want to set that and
the same goes for everybody who's on
this committee we may disagree I don't
sincerity uh further
discussion um I don't see any hands up
Mr chair I I I'm I'm sorry I I
I I'm sorry representative marjerie
Smith but I do take a little bit of
offense in that you're in insinuating
that we're voting against this because
you're of the a different
party and uh that is not the case um it
has been in
previous rules committee
meetings when the majority party is in
effect they
usually accomplish what their goals are
uh we have different
philosophies and if our philosophies are
different than yours I don't think we
should be chastised
for voting the way we feel is right um
You and I have had a long relationship
but I I do take some offense to that
representative Smith I'm sorry I did not
want to say that but I I just can't
insinuations representative Weber has
her hand up Mr represent Weber
thank you and I'm I'm sorry about
previous
um Expressions concern because I can
understand where they're coming from and
I I just want to speak personally for
myself and sort of redirect the
discussion and redirect the dog at the
same time uh redirect the discussion
about this particular issue
because I was
startled and horrified to find that on a
couple of occasions when I with the best
will in the
world um I'm I'm thinking of an occasion
where um uh I complimented a person of
African-American descent on something
for on something they've written
and I compliment people only when I
truly and sincerely mean a compliment
from the bottom of my heart what I had
not realized is that uh for many people
of African-American descent when they
are told by a white person that they
wrote something well what they hear in
their ears whatever I meant is I don't
believe you know how to write the
English language and I
think that in a time where all of us are
working hard at
reexamining how we relate to each other
different races people of different
backgrounds um and and this is not
limited simply to race issues um I think
that having a vehicle to start those
discussions and have those
um without questioning anybody's motives
for it is is really truly important and
that's why I support this U legislation
you I don't see any other hands up Mr
chair no further discussion
um I'm sorry representative CL I mean
clerk um what what motion the motion is
to accept uh the
Amendment as before you okay all right
thank you uh clerk o call roll
Osborne nope representative rice no
Representative Steven Smith no
representative
Sor no representative Cushing yes
represent
Sheriff yes represent Weber yes
representative Timothy Smith
yes the motion accept fails G to vote of
five to
screen uh represent Roger Smith thank
you very much Mr chair could I ask you
um a question um understanding the
difficulties of this system would it not
have been appropriate
when
um comments were
made uh specifically
criticizing uh something that I said to
give me an opportunity to respond I did
not have that opportunity and I just
wanted to raise that point um but I will
110 and what this does is try again to
make clear the importance of the role of
the
speaker in
determining how we are to function
within the
legislature when there are external
circumstances that have that are out of
our
control but where we then have to decide
how we can best function this supports
the um the language of the recent
Supreme Court ruling and helps to make
it possible for us to best meet the
health and safety requirements of all
members of the house and the public by
permitting a hybrid of both remote and
inperson
participation all of this being directed
by
um the
this uh representative
Weber I would move we accept this and I
would ask to speak to my motion second Z
second second and
seconds go ahead ribs water I would move
acceptance and um the the one of the
things I want to point out is that this
um we have adopted rules um unanimously
dealing with uh periods of
covid in the past we have had rules that
allow us to operate in times of enemy
attack
um whether covid was an enemy attack or
not was an issue um probably not what
was intended when that constitutional
amendment was adopted uh but this
amendment
specifically uh would allow us in the
event of some
other um unforeseen event that I I don't
know what it would be but it tracks uh
some legislation that other legislators
legislator have that in the event that
something else God
forbid horrible
happens that we have in our rules the
ability to deal with it and it requires
uh the speaker to make a determination
and it requires the concurrence of both
the majority and the minority leader
before this would come into effect and
um it it it would just
allow the legislature to continue in the
face of the next
unimaginable thing that comes along
because last December I had no idea that
we would be dealing with the issues that
we started dealing with in March and
continue to deal with now so I I urge
the
discussion uh representative Tim Smith
has his hand up representative Tim Smith
thank you Mr chairman um I would point
out that you know similar to to some of
the previous rule uh changes we've
considered I see this as empowering and
accommodating you know the the speaker
of the house and the house leadership um
as representative Weber had said uh you
know we don't know what sort of
disasters may come up in the future and
I I think that adding something like
this that creates uh a little bit more
of a broad
Authority um in an emergency situation
and you know it's not unchecked
Authority uh you know it involves the
the majority leader and the minority
leader in situations you know I mean
maybe an asteroid Falls from space who
the heck knows um where there's clear
and
uncontentious um situa uh circumstances
out in the public that you know create
the need for us to make some minor
alterations for how we do business um
that the speaker and the institution
don't find ourselves kneecapped by our
our own rules requirements um and and
need to go through you know Byzantine
procedure
uh that and and like find ourselves in a
situation where the procedure we need to
execute in order to give ourselves the
flexibility itself becomes an unworkable
procedure so that the nature of the
emergency precludes us from reacting to
the
emergency um to an extent that's the
situation we found ourselves in with a
viral pandemic um that I don't think
anyone would dispute
um you know society as a whole was not
really prepared for I mean it hasn't
happened in a hundred years like this um
and I I think adding this section to our
rules gives a little bit more
flexibility going forward and an extra
blanket of protection for you know
unforeseen
discussion uh I don't see any hands Mr
chairman I just um throw in a little bit
here
um this is something in uh that
U speak of short lift and um myself and
former speaker Hench uh in the
facilities committee has been looking
at for what two or three months now Mr
Speaker that's correct Mr Speaker and um
you you know we're still in the process
of trying to figure it all
out uh and I I think I can categorically
say along with the former
speaker everything that we have done up
to this point has to been to try and
make sure that the building is safe and
any member coming into the building is
going to be safe as possible it isn't
now but uh that is our goal
um I don't know if this
would curtail any of that or affect that
coming into effect but I'm cautious
about trying to put rules in place when
we have a working product in front of
us uh I I I'm just a real cautious about
that because there still are a lot of
unknowns and um I I just don't feel that
this is necessary at this time it may be
at some time that we could put something
like this together I just I just don't
feel it's necessary at this
time the only promise that I will make
to
you is if I am the speaker and I'm sure
you all know I'm running for it I will
make a absolute 100% commitment that I
would do nothing as speaker to endanger
any person
and
um representative
Weber thank you Mr Speaker and I
certainly appreciate that and and
understand it and and appreciate it from
the bottom of my heart um and I know
that you and the former speaker and
others uh have put an enormous amount of
effort into this um this does not
mandate anything and it only allow ows
the speaker to address with the majority
leader and the minority leader the next
problem that comes along that is
particularly intractable and it also
allows allows you should you choose to
do so uh to hold remote meetings it
makes it very clear that our rules allow
the holding of remote meetings now uh
should you determine that you need to do
so um and I I see that as being
completely unthreatening and and part of
the process going forward in that it
gives you a tool that you may use uh
both now with a
known difficulty and threat and in the
future with what may come along very
quickly without any uh knowledge on our
part of what it's going to be so um it
it would not in any way um supplant or
prevent the ongoing discussions that I
know that you're already engaged in in
terms of making arrangements going
forward it it doesn't require you to do
this it simply allows you one way of
dealing with an intractable problem if
the intractable problem is there so I
would I would urge the adoption because
it does not get in the way of any of the
things that you're already talking about
it it simply promotes one possibility
for moving forward should it be useful
to you thank you representative
shirtliff has his hand
up thank you chairman thank you um I
thank my friend from London dery for his
earlier comments but I'd also uh
publicly thank him for all the
cooperation I received uh from him over
the past two years um I don't want to
compliment you too much because I know
you have an election coming up in 48
hours so uh so I don't want to say too
many good things about you but anyway
um as the speaker knows um there was a
time during the last session when we
passed a similar rule to this in order
to get our business done in the 11th
Hour of the previous bium and there was
a time that I made a request and asked
the concurrence of the two leaders and
uh
one of the leaders said no and so what I
wanted to do didn't come about so there
is that check and balance but I think
whomever our our leader our speaker will
be in the uh next pium I think it gives
them an opportunity to have one more
arrow in their quiver in the event that
things should happen things that we may
never even think of at this moment to be
able to act and get the cooperation of
the two parties um as you know Mr
Speaker what we deal with last year was
far above partisan politics and I think
everybody tried to work in the best
interest of our staff our members in the
general public and I think this uh
Amendment would give the opportunity to
the next speaker to have this ability to
call on the leadership of the two
caucuses uh to get things done that need
to be done in a in a in
a quick manner in order to uh be act in
the best interests of the
um you and I have a um a good friendship
Mrs speaker yeah we have a good
friendship um um we disagree
philosophically a lot but uh you know I
I do consider you a good friend and I
would hope that who
ever is in the majority in the majority
in the
future would do that
automatically without having to have a
rule put in place I I I think I have
enough faith in us as
legislators and us as people to do
that and that's why I have a problem
with this type of an amendment because I
just feel
that if we can't work together on
something like that then there's a real
problem systemic problem and has to be
has to be fixed and I would hope
regardless of
our um philosophical dealings when it
comes to health and
safety of whatever might come you know
in the future that we would do that
automatically without having a rule
saying that you know we could do or have
to do it I I that's just me I guess I
just really believe that we would we
would do that
friend representative Cushing has his
hand up Mr chairman representative
kushin I'm sorry um I I just want to say
that I I share your sentiment about uh
an expectation that whomever is the
leader whatever party is in power that
in times of emergency we will work
together um and I you know and I that's
why consistent with that I think this is
a simple ground authority to whomever
the
speak in times of Crisis not with
the you know is as a as is the m is
representative of the minority um one
might think that I would be reluctant to
give overpower to the speaker at any
given moment but I'm perfectly you know
I I I will be supporting this because I
think that in times of emergency there
should be a clear uh delineation of
authority to the speaker with
consultation of course with a majority
but you know to act to take the steps
that are necessary to um you know in in
discussion if there be no further
discussion um would you
re refresh us on the
uh motion yes sir uh the motion is to
accept the amendment to rule um
110 U mov by representative Weber and
second by representative Sher okay thank
you Mr clerk would you please call a
rooll representative Packard uh no
representative
Osborne no representative rice
no Representative Steven Smith
no representative
Sanborn no representative Cushing yes
representative Sheriff yes
representative Weber yes representative
Timothy Smith
four we have one more from
representative
[Music]
Smith that should be on your screen
uh representative marjerie Smith
please thank you very much um Mr
chair
um we propose this amendment to rules in
the same way that we have proposed a
number of other
rules and while it appears that my
comments in the past were misunderstood
and for that I have great
regret um it gives me an opportunity to
reinforce here that these proposals were
made by the
minority knowing that we were in the
minority but determined
to make sure that the power of the
speaker was clear knowing that the
speaker would be of another party but
believing in the Integrity of the house
and the importance of the house being
able to function under circumstances
which we might not have anticipated we
wanted to give power to the speaker and
in fact I would make a minor little
change in this um amendment by saying
that um the word majority in the third
line should be
capitalized um so it's the majority and
the minority leader um but all this does
is to try to strengthen the role and the
power and acknowledge the power that the
speaker should have when there is an
emergency it isn't in fact the same
principle that has occurred in several
other uh proposals including the one
that was just voted down and I would ask
for your support for this because it is
important that it be clear that the
speaker has the authority and that in
order to overrule the actions of the
speaker it would take 2third of the
members of the House voting
thank
you sentive Weber has her hand raised Mr
chairman all right thank you uh Paul my
screen just went blank so you're GNA
have to in representative Weber I would
move that we accept the um
motion is there a
second
second uh discussion
representative um Weber and
representative Tim Smith have their
hands raised uh representative Weber I
would just say that un unlike the uh
earlier one which
contemplated a broad range of
circumstances um this one is very
severely limited and and would uh occur
only under state of emergency so uh it
it is a very limited extension of extra
powers to the speaker but um I think
it's one that as as we have seen might
be very useful so I urge its adoption
thank
you representative Tim Smith Mr chair
representative
Smith thank you um you know similar to
some of the other amendments that were
proposed um I I think that this provides
a a very important um sort of an escape
hatch uh you know for the speaker if we
find ourselves in another unfortunate
situation uh you know in this case a
state of emergency officially declared
you know through the executive branch of
the the state or the the federal
government um you know in that
unfortunate possible situation um I
would rather us have something in rules
where the speaker could you know take
some measures to move our meeting
location or change the time or move a
deadline you know or some other abstract
consideration we haven't really thought
of change the parking Arrangements you
know whatever um without having to worry
about inventing language to grant that
Authority and having it
inserted uh you know in some emergency
basis or or having that uh Authority you
know be an ambiguous matter that needs
to be submitted to the judicial branch
um to see if if the if the speaker even
has the authority to you know um move
our our parking Arrangements across the
street or something uh you know in a in
a state of
emergency um and as keeping with you
know a lot of other house traditions and
everything this this power uh of the
speaker is not unchecked there is that
provision at the end that members of the
House can override such an action just
to prevent the extremely unlikely
scenario of some kind of abuse um and
you know representative Cushing alluded
you know as a as a member of the
minority party this term it might not be
politically advantageous for me to
support giving more emergency power to a
speaker of the house who you know we can
do math is going to be from the other
party um but I I think as a practical
consideration it is extremely important
for the institution um that the speaker
uh have some Authority like this clearly
laid out in the rules without having to
just hope and you know rely on uh the
object is there representative Cushing
has his representative Cushing um just I
want to say as an institutionalist and
by that I mean someone who supports the
institution of our of the legislature
itself I just think that this is an
important rule for us to adopt um and
because it doesn't really matter who's
uh what part's in charge what really
matters is that whoever the speaker is
has the authority to act uh to in the
best interest of the house itself and
explicitly Representative Steve Smith
SM thank you Mr chair the my concern
with this is the there's no limitation
on this so in the case of an emergency
if we have a big storm sometimes
emergency is declared so that we can
qualify for FEMA funds does this mean
that or not it isn't defined um and then
anytime there is an emergency let's
assume the speaker the majority leader
and the minority leader all get along
pretty well they can literally do
anything they want because there's no
scope here um no limitations and then
the members of the House well they can
always overr it override it by a
two-thirds vote but what if one of the
things a speaker does is not have any
sessions for a while
so I think we already have the ability
to move deadlines as necessary but to
just let three people in any case have a
uh you know ultimate Authority instead
of a 400 member
legislature I I can't support it without
definitions is anybody else wish to
speak representative Tim Smith has his
hand up again okay representative Smith
uh thank you um just a quick followup to
the the concerns raised by um the other
representative Smith um there is some
limiting of the scope in there it it
does specifically say uh take such
actions as is necessary to ensure the
continued operations of the house um so
it it it is at least limited to that
particular um you know scope of
authority
discussion if not uh would you uh yes
sir repeat the mo uh repeat the uh
motion and uh then call a roll please
yes sir this is a motion to accept the
amendment as on your
screens representative Packard no
representative
Osborne no representative rice
no Representative Steven Smith no
Representative
sorne no representative Cushing yes
representative Sheriff yes
representative Weber yes representative
Timothy Smith
yes
the motion to accept
fails
five question of the
chair yes ah it's back yes um Mr Speaker
I was wondering if it would be possible
for us to take a short three minute
break so that some of us who've been
sitting here for three hours might
attend to something quickly uh
representative kushen I was going to
suggest five minute break I agree with
you Mr chair at this point uh let me let
me just mention we we will stay um the
the the the meeting will continue to run
um on but we W but as at your by your
leave we will take that F minute recess
uh representative Smith has presented
all of her amendments so I would just
like to uh thank her for for being with
us this this morning and into the
afternoon and I also thank
representative Smith for her uh absolute
diligence and putting all these
forward uh even though we disagree and
some of them uh I thank her for bringing
them forward uh yeah if we uh I think we
could all use a five minute break I get
up and walk around myself for a few
minutes and whatever other functions
that need to
happen so I see it's 5 1254 by my clock
uh if I think I'm right so let's
okay
um Mr clerk uh
Paul uh for some reason or other my
screen just went blank and now it just
came back on do you know have have a
reason why that might have happened that
may have been uh with the um a problem
with the amendment uh showing on your
your screen uh when when that comes back
up we should be able to um it looks fine
now but uh I just last it for a few
okay just a quick announcement for those
that are in the um uh the gall
um we do not um take public uh comment
you
for
e
was all
my apologies for the phone I thought I
chairman remember down at the the bottom
microphone there you
go am I unmuted now you are okay thank
you I guess we can get going is
everybody
back okay uh next up we have have uh
representative Prout if you give me a
here representa BR can you hear me I can
can you hear me yes sorry I'm back I I
hope no one was waiting for me you're
fine
represent proud would you like to deal
with this
numerically uh numerically works all
25 thank you hang on just a moment let
chairman uh go ahead representer
Prout thank you uh this amendment does
uh three things uh first it adds a
clarifying mention that joint rules do
not always exist uh this really confused
me at first I misook what I was
referencing to to the alignment of
deadlines in our calendar with the other
body uh joint rules haven't been adoped
Ed since the 1995 96 session uh I think
it's u a bit awkward to have a reference
in our rules to something that doesn't
exist and I think this annotation uh on
line two there will make it much
clearer uh second it clarifies that a
notice or reconsideration cannot hold up
a bill pass the applicable deadline to
act or crossover in our house rules uh
previously the reference was only to Jo
joint rules uh this has been the way we
operate already but I think this tries
to just make it a lot clearer
uh third and this is what is directly
related to the situation I encountered
with the late introduction of House Bill
1717 regarding Growlers last year this
rule makes reconsiderations out of order
after a bill has been read a third time
if we were acting on that bill pass the
applicable deadline pursu to pursuing to
a rule
suspension the audity that house bill
1717 ran into is once the deadlines are
suspended for a bill that suspension
stands in made the notice of
reconsideration in order consequently my
bill was held in the house until the
notice of reconsideration expired and
missed any practical time period for the
Senate to act on it uh please note that
this would uh only affect motions to
reconsider and notice of
reconsideration uh that would affect
both uh so a motion for an immediate
third reading on Bill would act to
similar to a failed motion to reconsider
if we are acting on a bill passed its
deadline via suspension of the rules for
deadlines it's my understanding
understanding that uh provided the bill
was still in possession of the house a
rule suspension to reconsider would
still be in order so we could do that to
fix any issues such as uh forgetting to
adopt a relevant Amendment or other
problems not that's ever happened
before uh thank you for your
consideration I'd be happy to take any
questions uh okay first of all
um I'll motion to
second
discussion representative Cushing has
his hand up
chair thank you Mr
chairing thank you
thank you Mr chair I don't see the
discussion
okay what's CH I'm sorry I I was just
saying I don't see any okay there' be no
further hands uh the motion is to accept
Clerk or call a roll
representative Packard
yes representative
Osborne
yes representative rice yes
Representative Steven Smith yes
representative
Sor yes representative Cushing
no Representative shiff no
representative Weber no representative
Timothy Smith
35 um can I just speak briefly to both
43 recognizes you
they are uh yes you may speak yes um
point of order
two point I just point I thought our
practice was to only discuss one
proposed amendment at a
time
I you're right representative I think I
know what this is going to be I will
separate them if it's not what I think
it's going to be and point of order may
we have them on screen please I'm sorry
certainly may we have them on the screen
please oh yes y um I I I guess before we
go much further is it your intention
representative Prout not to offer these
two correct and I just wanted to to just
make a brief comment as to why I'm not
offering them okay and that's that's why
I I thought this was coming that's why I
uh allowed that to happen Okay so if
nobody has an objection he can offer a
brief comment but neither one of these
are going to be offered go ahead
representative Prout thank you uh so I I
asked the clerk to draft both of these
because um as in my speech on
organization day I promised to ensure uh
to mention to the rules committee all
the changes uh from the previous term
that were not brought forward by someone
else to make sure that you know they are
not forgotten and we leave them aside
intentionally and so these two were
those two uh I I'm not the right person
to Champion them however all the other
ones someone else picked up the ball to
Champion them and uh I'm not going to
bring them forward at this time unless
someone had a specific request that I do
uh thank you representative
Prout can we go on to the next one Mr
okay were we not just told that this one
was not going to be offered I know no
representative that was uh 30 and uh 40
43 I beg your pardon thank you for the
clarification uh represent
pro thank you this amendment would allow
members to request late Drafting and the
house to consider resolutions that evoke
statutory Authority without the
suspension of rules or prior rules
committee approval
I've asked OLS research for a list of
these and there were three sections of
Statute that provided for this two and
RSA 445 to declare and to terminate a
state of emergency and one in RSA 490
col
6-a to terminate an emergency order
issued by the Supreme Court during a
state of
emergency as you can see they all relate
to emergency
situations emergency situations don't
happen when it's convenient they don't
follow our legislative deadlines an LSR
filing window our current process of
putting these types of resolutions
through the normal Bill filing system of
deadlines really makes the legislature
uh impotent during an
emergency uh that impedence uh causes
creates a culture of ignoring the
legislature during an emergency not even
Consulting us sometimes not even
informing us I think it's critically
important to break that culture even if
the legislature as a whole is in favor
of everything that is being done under
the current state of emergency the
culture of indicating all power and
authority is dangerous and antithetical
to our system of constitutional
government and this rule is about more
than the current state of emergency as
well as I said for me it's about setting
the culture in tone of how government
branches interact for the future I think
this is especially true regarding the
legislature's ability to declare a state
of emergency I can't see how this
section would ever be practical to use
given the roadblocks in place to
exercising
it uh thank you for your consideration
and I'd be happy to take any questions
representative uh Smith has a question
Mr chair uh why don't we get a motion
first uh Mr
Clark I'll move not to
accept
second okay uh say representative Tim
Smith yes sir okay representative
Smith uh thank you um this this might be
a question either for representative
proud or for um our clerk I'm not sure
which but if I'm understanding the
intent of this correctly um and I I
really want to hope that I do uh because
if I'm correct on on what you're trying
to do here this might be kind of
important
um is it not already possible for
someone to ask OSS at any time to draft
something it's only the introduction of
something after it's drafted um that
would require you know suspension of the
rules and the deadline lines and I I ask
that from a position of ignorance you
know I've never tried to introduce
anything outside of the regular schedule
so I I don't know what the process is if
you go to OS and ask them to draft a
bill in the middle of
February Mr chair I I can address that
thank you um OS will not accept a
request for late drafting unless they
have unless you've had approval from the
rules
committee okay sorry may I ask a
followup yes go ahead and representative
so the the current process would be that
um the representative or you know the
theoretical representative not
representative Prout the the
representative who wanted to
introduce one of these uh concurrent
resolutions you know invoking statutory
Authority would first need the approval
of the rules committee before asking OS
to to actually do the the drafting of
the language that that is correct
currently would this change uh any
member could go to OS and and ask for
that to be drafted and it would be
drafted and its introduction uh even
after the deadline um and any subsequent
action uh would only require a majority
vote that includes um waving public
hearing
you uh for representer Weber thank you
Mr chair I uh appreciate the sentiments
that uh representative uh Prout
suggested um and and I I share his
concerns uh I'm also concerned about the
language about of any resolution
invoking statutory Authority because it
does not appear to me that that's as
limited as uh the
representative um expressed to us
um there's an awful lot of things that
invoke statutory Authority and so for
that for that reason I think this is too
broad and I'm going to vote against it
thank you uh further
discussion uh representative kushin yes
um that representative Weber um
expressed my concern about the broadness
of what statutory Authority are I see
lots of statutory Authority and I'm
concerned that this is just this could
be a way to kind of circumvent the
regular deadlines that are in place for
um request ing Drafting and I just think
that we should stick with the existing
process I think it works well for
us did you have your hand up
representative Tim Smith I did um now
that I I got an answer to my question
I'd like to share my my thoughts on this
um I I don't have any strong objections
or concerns about the introduction I'm
sorry about the the
drafting um under these circumstances
you know where a member is trying to do
like a um an HCR you know to invoke
statutory Authority on something um but
my my concern is that second part about
any subsequent consideration shall
require only a minority vote um you know
that's sort of regardless of any other
factors um If This Were amended in such
a way to remove that last bit about only
requiring a minority vote to pass
respective the deadlines I I would find
myself in support of this um I
personally I don't have any issue with a
member getting something drafted you
know um to invoke statutory Authority as
long as it's introduced um through the
you know the normal process respective
to
deadlines um representative Osborne had
Osborne oh sorry I had taken my hand
down but I will say you know I
yeah I I appreciate uh where this is
coming from and uh and what it's trying
to do I I I just without being able to
think through all of the possible
um uh future um ramifications I I I I
would be scared to uh suggest that we uh
if if uh I may at this point um
representative
Prout from the comments
made I think that
[Music]
um if you were to um withdraw this at
its time and come back further with
maybe some more clarity and um you know
maybe a little bit
tighter um you know I think a lot of us
would probably go along with it but I
agree that I'm hearing
you I I think that you're a little bit
it's a little bit too broad right now
and I I don't think that we've we've
considered all the um ramifications this
could have at at some point in a future
house session and I guess that's why I'm
a little concerned about it the way it
uh it's written right now um it it could
cause regardless of the party and who's
in power it could cause some disruption
I think in the uh in the uh in the house
session thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you to all members of the committee for
your comments and feedback and I would
be be given that I would be happy
withdraw it at this
time all right and I I I think you know
we'd be glad to work with you
representative proud to see if we can
come to uh you know some some good
language that we can all accept
uh representative Prout uh would you
like to move forward with rule 57 yes
okay uh go ahead represent Prout let me
chair thank you uh this rule is about
speeches under unan consent of the house
usually near the end of our day after
the third reading
motion uh the current process is that if
unanimous consent is withdrawn it
triggers a vote on if the members should
be allowed to continue with the consent
of the house this currently requires a
simple majority of those present this
rule would require a two-thirds majority
of those present for the member to
continue
speaking we had several instances of
issues with this last term where it came
down to a Partyline vote I don't think
it serves anyone well nor the house as
an institution to have party line votes
on this topic even though the majority
has switch parties this year this is an
area where I think it makes sense to
have the rights of minority respected
and that speeches like this should only
be made with uh unanimous or near
unanimous agreement of the
members and this rule would Implement
that by saying the bar
two-thirds uh I would also like to note
that um representative Jess Edwards
worked with me and I think it was
intention his intention to co-sponsor it
I see the clerk doesn't have that and uh
he's not present here so I can't get him
to put his name on it automatically I
don't think unless you feel that that
was the content of his last email to you
but uh thank you for your consideration
and be happy to take any
uh is there a
motion representer wbor you have your
hand
up uh I'll I'll motion to
accept is there a
second
representative shff has his hand up okay
I can't see him but go ahead
representative
sherff thank you Mr chair uh Mr chair
I'll be voting against this um there are
times in the past I think when all of us
have seen people speak on the floor that
we wish weren't up there and saying what
they were
saying maybe 50% of the vote or 50% Plus
one is uh too low a bar maybe it should
be
60% but I think to to to request a 23s
vote to deny a member of the House to
speak under unanimous
consent gives an awful strong position
to the majority party um representative
Prout mentioned about the rights of the
minority I think the rights of the
minority are infringed when the majority
can simply say
no you can't vote with a 2third vote uh
necessary in order to uh to be able to
speak that's just too big a hurdle to
try to get over and I think what we're
doing now with a 50% majority of vote
works and I just don't think there's any
need and I think this is infringes on
body thank you further discussion
uh representative Tim Smith
Representative Steve Smith and
representative Cushing is your hand up
or not no sorry I'm just
listening um so representative Tim Smith
and then Representative Steve Smith
thank
you um yeah I I kind of share the set
sentiment of Representative shirtliff um
but I I also look at this from the
opposite point of view that um you know
it may not be politically advantageous
for me to oppose this but um this
presents enormous opportunity for for
abuse by both the majority and the
minority um to just shut down anyone who
we don't like what they're saying um you
know as far as I can recall in my time
in the house I have never voted um to
deny somebody unanimous consent the few
times where there's actually been a vote
on it regardless of what I thought about
what they're saying um and I I worry
that that this brings us down a slippery
slope and sets a dangerous precedent
where you know the the ability of
members to to speak their mind and and
execute you know per Personal Privilege
like unanimous consent um is this going
to bounce back and forth uh between
parties you know not necessarily this
term but maybe eight terms from now um I
I don't like where this is going at all
um and I'm definitely going to be voting
against this I I think it just it just
abuse Representative Steve
Smith thank you Mr chair the the members
that have talked to me that that were
frustrated about this asked a really
good question is it unanimous consent or
not it's really not intuitive to a lot
of them and causes outrage when they
find out that unanimous consent is just
two words that don't mean a thing and
then we can go vote and say yeah you
know your unanimous consent didn't
matter there are very few times where
one representative in this giant C that
we have in the legislature has any power
one is the consent calendar that's
unanimous consent any one of us can say
no um in this case I've seen members of
both parties object to unanimous consent
over the time I've been in the
house and if we have a thing called
unanimous consent uh it it should be and
it should
be it just should be harder I'm I will
vote for this um and look forward to
people from maybe both parties working
with me to find a more intuitive way to
define what you can do and what you
can't
um but we have to start the conversation
and this is a good way to do
it representative Tim Smith has raised
his hand Mr chairman Tim
Smith so I I would um find myself in a
bit of agreement with uh what
Representative Steve Smith mentioned and
i' I think a question to the clerk to to
clarify might be in order but my current
understanding is that if unanimous
consent is
withdrawn then the motion where we vote
to let the person continue talking it no
longer is unanimous consent they are
simply speaking by consent of the house
not by unanimous consent consent of the
house um so it it already is as my
understanding holds it um it already is
something different and it's not
unanimous consent if it comes down to
that vote is uh Mr clerk is is my
understanding of the procedure on that
correct uh Mr chair may I answer the
question yes you may uh you are correct
representative Smith if if unanimous
consent is withdrawn uh and a vote is
put to the body uh a member is is
allowed to continue their they speaking
with the consent of the house not
unanimous but with consent of the
house followup Mr chairman for the
question so I I I would I would say that
you know given that what we just
clarified rather than introducing this
rule change it might behoove us a little
better to just simply educate our
incoming members um a little bit more uh
precisely about the Nuance of that
situation rather than you know go
through the the heavy step of a rules
chairman okay I'm I'm I'll abstain from
speaking on this um if there be no
further questions
um uh no further discussion Clerk call a
roll the uh motion is to accept the
amendment as uh shown on your screen
representative Packard
yes representative
Osborne yes representative rice yes
Representative Steven Smith yes
representative
sorn yes representative Cushing
no representative Sheriff no
representative Weber no representative
Timothy Smith
then amendment to 65 as we've adopted it
screen uh represent proud go
ahead thank you Mr
Speaker uh so this amendment would uh
add an additional item to the calendar
of deadlines uh that this committee
approved earlier in this meeting uh for
a last day to concur with Senate
amendments to house bills uh I think uh
it was interesting to to learn last year
uh in the process that we found oursel
in that that didn't already exist and uh
I noticed that it was in the proposed
calendar last year that failed to reach
the two-thirds majority to be uh adopted
on our uh I believe June 11th meeting um
and say uh as a member I was a little
bit surprised that we didn't have a
deadline for this already and that
essentially uh amendments to house bills
could be accepted all the way through
the end of the session you know even if
that you know is on veto day um and uh
it's something I would like to see in
our calendar uh proposed uh the date the
same day as the last day to for form
Committees of conferences but I do think
it needs as a as an option but I do
think it needs to be in C or somewhere
so it's just not
open-ended and uh thank you for
questions reprentative Tim
Smith thank you um a question for
representative Prout um we get Mr SMI
representative
Smith sorry no not a motion I had a
question yeah can I get a motion first
and then we can go on to the questions
and
motion represent I I I guess I'll make
the motion to accept but I I don't know
whether uh I I I should vote for it or
not okay well we can have the discussion
repres Smith Steph Smith oh Steph Smith
okay uh representative ten Smith now
that we have a formal Motion in a second
thank you I I apologize for for jumping
the gun Mr chairman I'm I'm I'm more
accustomed to regular committee
procedure where we go back and forth um
so my my question for representative
prow would the would the net eff of this
be to prevent a situation like we had
last term um where the Senate kind of
Amalgamated you know 50 to 60 house
bills together as one big Amendment onto
a house bill um because of the you know
the situation they ran into where they
didn't um why I shouldn't say anything
about that but um the the situation that
they ran into where some of their bills
weren't necessarily being acted on uh
because of the the emergency we found
ourselves then so I don't think it would
directly uh thank you for the question
by the way I don't think it would
directly speak to that issue as you
stated it and the reason I say that is
is I believe um the Senate always has
sometimes especially in the second year
of the BM merged multiple Bill bills
together and sent them back to us I
don't think and I don't think this
amendment would do anything for uh that
situation I I won't go so far as to call
it a problem um I don't think this
amendment would speak at all to that
situation really only the calendar onto
when that could happen um that they
would you know that there that there is
a I always looked at the calendar and
thought that there was a you know a
deadline for us to either accept Senate
amendments or form a committee
conference and I guess at first I never
realized that there really is no
deadline for us to accept sen amendments
you know that can be all the way through
the end of uh the normal session year at
the end of June or it there's no appears
to be no prohibition against us doing it
through the summer all the way into you
know the fall and veto day to just vote
to accept uh any bill that's been
hanging out and we haven't acted on it
already and that's what this would
really address is that there's any bill
with a senate Amendment pending that
falls way late into the
calendar it would require a rule
suspension to take action on
it but not necessarily speak to how much
or how meaty the amendment that came
from the Senate
is hopefully that answered your
question Mr M Mr clerk could you
probably maybe give us some
clarification I I would be happy to and
and and I note that Representatives
Cushing Tim Smith and Weber had hands up
um so so just to just to go back for a
moment addressed uh last year's
situation um if you recall uh last year
was a a very different circumstance than
than what we were under and that that
will have been the only time in in in
recent recent memory and and by my
recent memory I can say the last 35
years um where you will have seen a last
data concur with Senate amendments to
house bills uh being put forward that
was done um explicitly at the time
because of the uh truncated um time
frame in which we were trying to deal um
with the ability to have hearings
remotely and to get things done on the
floor um in an expedited manner um so
that that the appearance of this
language last June was uh sort of a an
aberration of of what um the normal
practice is this is this would not be um
something that that is is custom for the
body um and one of those one of the many
reasons for that is that it does sort of
uh handicap um the individual uh bodies
in and by that I mean the the house or
the senate in being able to deal with
you know last minute emergencies or um
things of that nature um if you were
going to introduce this and put this in
it it it might be better placed at the
to put it in is the last day uh to put
it in so that it concurs with the last
day to act on Committees of conference
perhaps um or something along those
lines but I I I think at this point um
you know this this this is definitely
sort of speaking outside of the the
realm of
custom all Rob sen cushion yeah my
concern has to do with the the the
dynamic between the house and the Senate
and I'm concerned that where we don't
have joint rules and we don't even
necessarily have and the Senate sets its
own deadlines I don't want us to get in
a position where we end up um having
good house bills die because the Senate
hasn't the Senate schedule doesn't fit
our schedule um and there are sometimes
that a you know a house bill you know it
could be changed in effective date
there's minor changes or friendly
amendments that we would want to have uh
readily adopt and I just don't want us
to be in a situation where our own
deadline precludes us from concurring
with good house with house bills that
have been um acted on by the senate i it
seems like we we're it's a setup to kill
our own
bills R Tim
Smith so my
um I I understand where uh where
representative proud is coming from on
this and um my my questions were were
addressed uh very satisfactorily thank
you um my only
hesitation is because of what happened a
couple of terms ago where the house
failed to pass a budget um and the other
chamber was
forced to craft a state budget and graft
it as an amendment you know onto a
non-gain house bill relatively late in
the cycle and I I worry that you know if
we find ourselves not even necessarily
this term but in a in a future term if
we find ourselves in a situation where
we don't pass a house budget and the
other chamber has to
scramble
um you know June 10th might not you know
or the the other deadlines that line up
on June 10th that that might not be uh
really conductive to to them actually
being able to get it done and we might
find ourselves in the unenviable
position where we need a two-thirds vote
to suspend our rules to allow the
introduction of the state budget because
it's being presented as an amendment to
a house bill coming out of the Senate
rather than as um you know the the
original House bill that was filed you
know in December as the placeholder um
that's that's my my real concern with
this and because of that I'm I'm afraid
I can't it but I I will say that I could
probably be convinced to support some
similar language if that was
addressed for the discussion oh Mr clerk
no representative Weber Mr chair oh I'm
sorry represent Weber thank you um I I
just um following on the comments of the
house Clerk and also the comments of
Representative Cushing I think that this
is an area in which it would be very
unwise for for us uh to depart from our
our usual customary practices of of
decades uh particularly in terms of
surrendering the power of the house to
the Senate we get caught up in that a
lot and i' I'd rather not have us
further hamstrung thank
discussion I guess this has ridden uh R
risen a lot of concerns and and
unanswered questions on this uh and I
think I know where representative Pro
wants to go but I'm I'm not sure
representative Pro if you're there yet
um considering the concerns that uh have
been
risen
um what I would strongly suggest and
this is completely up to you is is of
maybe
um you know at a future rules committee
meeting you could um you could come back
and and present something
else certainly Mr Speaker I would be
happy to withdraw at this time and and
come back later um if I may take a
moment just to add one extra comment yes
um so really also what I was trying to
address with this was the idea that
through the calendar the Senate could
put us in a take it or leave it position
because once the deadline to form
committees a conference has passed
that's the position we're in it's a take
it or leave it um it's not a let's form
a committee conference and work out the
differences and so that's that is part
of the reason why I chose that same
deadline um but I'm happy to at this
time withdraw it and uh bring it back in
the future and uh have more discussion
offline sounds like a plan thank you
representative
I
think I think that does it for
representative
representa next we have representative
Tim Smith um
uh M oh Mr I'm sorry I was looking at my
my files um I so just just for clarity
um proposals I I did them in in time
order so that's that's why so
representative verville is uh is up next
okay all right I I CAU me by surprise I
was yeah sorry I I apologize I was I was
looking at my files in the in the folder
okay so uh let me just see where he
is
rep um I don't believe representative
us not with us I don't believe he is so
we will we will move over uh for now and
representative Abramson I did see him a
moment
ago uh Max Abramson there we
go representative Abramson is joined you
up how are you folks doing this
afternoon fine representative abon
you're good to
is um this is a the amendment or this
proposed rule change is similar to uh
what representative Prout brought up um
it is uh of course very different
wording I understand that uh you've just
ruled on uh um the other uh
representative prout's Amendment but uh
it deals with the issue that we have
house resolution sometimes they deal
with current events issues for example
the passing of U uh representative hinch
um but also the uh um the uh emergency
uh uh rules by the governor um sometimes
things happen in the middle of session
and someone wants to propose a house rle
or a house resolution to uh memorialize
someone or something or an attack or
something that's happened like the
September 11th attack uh can happen at
any time during the year um the other
reason for proposing this allowing house
resolutions and concurrent resolutions
to be brought in later in the term is to
try to encourage members who have the
idea for a house resolution I have uh I
have a couple up myself uh that are in
drafting and um rather than uh for
something in particular that isn't a
policy bill or that isn't Bound for the
the Senate is just to delay that until
later in the session maybe even until
April or May when uh things are slowing
down and we have only a handful of
Senate bills to deal with um I don't
believe that we should try to um adapt
to the current rules and deadlines that
the state senate has because the state
senate changes
their uh changes their deadlines and
changes their rules in the same way we
change our rules oh here comes my
cat
um and um we can't we can't uh depend on
on what they're going to do over time so
understand that prout's uh amend M does
almost the same thing and uh if uh you
want me to get back with him uh maybe we
can uh uh work out what what type of
wording members of the committee want to
forward oops so is is it your intention
representative Aon to withdraw this at
this time um I want I wanted to get
input from the rules committee before um
okay
um if you might consider taking it off
um let me um tell you what um I think my
concern is and and maybe some of the
other members concern is is the last
sentence uh any house resolution or C
time what few of us discussed was that
with that
language the minority
party towards the end of a session day
could flood the body with innumerable
amount of uh of uh resolutions or
concurrent
resolutions um just to cause um chaos in
a manner of
speaking and I have a real concern that
um I would hope that would never happen
but to me this opens that up for for it
to allow it to happen uh that
um if one party or the other was a
little bit upset about something what
the other party did and they came in
with 20 to 30 resolutions or house
resolutions uh it would would um not
only throw a wrench into the spikes as I
call it but throw take the whole wheel
off so to me that's a serious concern
that I think needs to be addressed
before I could uh you know approve some
I mean why I could vote for something
like
this let uh move it to the I've got my
house rules book open move it to the
deadline of
um the same as the last oh sorry my cat
just jumped in my lap last day to act on
Committee of conference reports which is
June we could set that as U cat we could
move the the the come on sorry out
[Music]
buy just jumped in right in the middle
of hearing what's that representative
Weber has her hand up MREs Weber has go
ahead wees Weber I just want to add the
comment to to yours Mr chairman that uh
it would not necessarily take the entire
minority party it could be just several
members of the house or even a single
member of the House who would able to
grind matters to a complete Halt and uh
it doesn't matter what we set for a
deadline that would be irrelevant so I I
think that this is a matter that really
requires a great deal more thought and
discussion before it's as we say ready
for Prime Time thank you and if I just
may jump in at this point uh I think it
was before your time representative
Benson but a past member threatened to
pull I think it was like 100 100
um bills off the ENT calendar because
they were upset at something I don't
even remember what it was so you know
this to me has the
same connotation of being U something
that could really cause some
problems I think that was during my time
as a matter wasn't that um yes 2015 or
2016 M from man I want to get into the
member's name or anything like that but
the situation did happen uh and and I if
I remember we were able to squash some
of it but that's not saying it couldn't
happen in the future or this could be uh
just absolutely 20 or 30 or 40
resolutions introduced by you know as as
representative Weber said one or two
members uh that could really really U
file things
up uh represent question do you have
your hand up I just I I I want to agree
with what you had to say and also with
what representative Weber had to say and
also say that you know there if there's
a matter of urgency that needs um a
resolution then it's we can just move to
suspend all the rules that usually the
majority minority leader together will
move to suspend the rules to take it up
right then or there's always the the
possibility you can come back before the
rules committee and asked to have the
rules suspended for late introduction
yeah yeah I I I think there are some men
other methods of uh doing this
representative abenson other than taking
the possibility of opening it up to uh
uh
misuse well someone can do that right
now anyone who's got a the manual the
general court can pop that open and and
look for ways to uh to filibuster we've
seen that not every session but we've
seen attempts to filibuster and keep us
uh in session for a very long period of
time um and we have seen uh there's
still some duplicate bills I pulled uh
three of my bills because they were four
of my bills because they were similar to
other people's bills but you can have
you can have members uh abuse the system
right now pretty badly um I I don't
that's I don't think that that's reason
enough I think that that the that
members who have house resolutions
should delay them until uh the
springtime but my other concern is
obviously the September 11th attack
happened in September um and any
memorializing or any house resolution or
uh house condemnation of an act or or or
a policy position for example an
HCR
um responding to uh the the governor's
emergency orders we didn't have the
ability as the
house um coming to session to challenge
that uh either the minority party or the
majority party could effectively
prevent um that question from beinging
being brought forward even though there
was a tremendous amount of public
interest and concern for that issue and
a lot of our business Community hurt by
that um but the main thrust of this of
course is to try to take a pretty good
sized number of HRS and hcrs and uh um
that come up and and kind of bog us down
in January and February and try to push
it till after budget day crossover day
well we never formally took a motion and
uh if you uh wish to have us move
forward with a vote we'll do that um so
um I guess I'll well I'll with I I'll
I'll take your um uh concerns to heart
and I'll withdraw this motion um and
I'll talk to uh representative Prout and
uh see if we can work something
out that's a that's a that's a good plan
representative avenson very good plan
forward okay let me see if
us I do not believe that he
has so uh representative Timothy
Smith is now
should be on your
screen thanks I'll um I'll step around
to the the other side of the the table
for a minute or
two so decades ago um the New Hampshire
house made history by being I believe
the first but if not one of the first
legislative Chambers in the country to
Institute that every Bill introduced
gets an up or down vote on the floor of
the house we removed the ability of
individual committee chairs to be
Gatekeepers on
legislation
um we now take that for granted and I I
think the vast majority of members of
the house would recognize that as a
positive
development however at the time it was
seen as highly controversial um because
it was you know a somewhat dramatic
shift uh away from the the Norms that
existed
then and you know it's only now decades
later that that we recognize how Forward
Thinking and historic that is um and and
certainly a lot of us probably wish that
other states in the federal Congress
uh operated in a similar
manner last term the New Hampshire house
made history Again by being the first
legislative chamber in the country to
recognize the rights of the people we
represent to be heard with preference
over the paid special interest lobbyists
you know who bring a sponsored point of
view um to the
legislature and uh one of the side
effects of the the way that the rules
were changed on organization day um is
that you know this was uh one of the
things that was removed kind of as
collateral damage um and so my my
introduction is just restoring The
Identical language to house rule 100
that committee chairs will ensure on a
best effort basis that members of the
public are recognized to testify at
public hearings before individuals
properly identified as lobbyists um um
all of the the commentary when I
presented this two years ago uh still
applies I believe all of us were were in
the house then um so I I won't drone on
you know with a lot of the same
arguments um other than to say that
after this was adopted by the house um
and you know got out there and was
noticed by the Press um this proved to
be
enormously popular with the general
public regardless of party regardless of
ideology regardless of you know advocacy
groups or anything else everybody out
there loved this I I even got some
positive feedback from some registered
lobbyists um saying that introducing a
measure like this um you know it helped
them defend the Integrity of their
profession by saying look we're not
getting special treatment and and I I
think they they had some Merit to that
argument I would challenge
anyone to find even one member of the
general public who is not you know a
retired state legislator who opposes
this um I think that this change does a
very good job of actually representing
the people who elected us of empowering
the people who elected us and I I
realize it's easy to to take something
like this and just casually miss it as
no we should just you know leave the
committee chairs Alone um but decades
ago you know we were brave enough to
take the take the stance that the
committee chairs are not going to get to
serve as Gatekeepers on
legislation and I would very humbly ask
the members of the rules committee to
once again allow the house to be brave
enough again and make history again to
retain the rule change that we're not
going to have committee chairs be
Gatekeepers against members of the
public um and with that I will take
questions um and I'll step back around
needed uh I see
representative thank you Mr chair and uh
Mr chair you and myself and several
people on this committee have been
committee chairs so I asked a question
uh of the member from Manchester under
the the word the verbage best effort
when a committee chair determines that
it's in the best interest of the
committee and to expedite a hearing to
hear from a lobbyist U before hearing
from the general public would that be
permissible under this rule
change it wouldn't be covered by this
rule change if someone regardless of who
they are um and again I I mentioned this
a couple of years ago but I'm happy to
mention it to clarify um if somebody is
invited by the committee to testify um
you know that's not the same thing as
someone showing up and just randomly
signing the pink sheet which is the
scenario this is addressing um and the
language on a best effort basis um you
know that's that's there to assume some
good faith on the part of the the
committee chair it's entirely possible
and we've all seen it happen that
someone will show up and sign in to
testify
and you know they're a lobbyist and they
don't mention that they're a lobbyist on
the pink sheet not out of any malicious
intent just you know the way they signed
it or the group they signed is
representing or maybe they forgot or
they're new or whatever um and and
nobody's at fault in those situations so
that's the purpose of the phraseology
best effort basis is to make it clear
that no one's at fault um in that sort
of a situation but to answer your
question very specifically this would
not curtail in any way the authority of
a committee chair to invite in someone
um you know as a special guest of the
committee in advance um to testify on
the bill and to place them wherever they
wanted in the speaking
order I don't want to Bel the point but
just to be clear um for example as I
think I've mentioned to you I introduced
a bill one time on behalf of the
domestic violence Co Coalition uh
non-fatal strangulation I knew a bit
about the bill but the lady s sitting
behind me knew far more she was actually
a lobbyist coming from the domestic
violence Coalition she wasn't invited by
the committee wasn't invited by the
chair but I asked her to be there to
speak so if the chair recognized CH next
to explain the intricacies of that bill
would that be permissible under this
house rule
change no if the committee chair did not
um you know make some arrangements to
invite that person to speak if it was
the the person introducing the bill um
that would be in contravention of this
rule okay thank
you all right uh before we go any
further uh we never never got a u a
recommendation on this a motion to
um uh you're the you're presenting it I
I can't accept a motion from you
represent question then I I'll move to
accept
it I will
second okay um seeing that you presented
representative uh Smith I if you're
asked the question obviously answer it
but uh I would ask that you not
participate in the discussion at this
point um is there any further discussion
okay
um representative Osborne are you
talking yes I
see if that's
okay yeah representative Osborne yeah uh
so I I guess um a couple
things just this just doesn't seem to me
something that belongs in house rules
this is the job of the committee chairs
to uh to manage uh the process and and
their respons responsibility is to do so
with the uh you know the best interests
of of our constituents in mind uh it it
is not clear to me that it is
necessarily in the um our constituents
Advantage for lobbyists to get the last
word in uh in in committee hearings uh
there I'm sure there's lots of different
reasons why you might want to get them
out of the way first and then let the
people have the last word so I I don't I
don't think this is a good
idea thank you
um I also obviously have been a uh
chairman for 12 years at different
points and I would hope that any
chairman respects the public that are
coming in to
testify but in many
cases
a department head or in some cases
lobbyists have much more in
information to present on a subject
matter than somebody from the public
might it's absolutely imperative that
the public uh be brought up as soon as
possible but sometimes the public
doesn't have all the information that
maybe a lobbyist or a department head
might have that could help uh Identify
some of the subject matter I I just
I just truly believe that if we whoever
the majority is trains their chairman
properly that we don't need this
particular piece of
legislation that's just my feeling I
think it it not that it's maybe going to
totally uh prevent the chairman from
doing their job but I certainly think it
does put a handicap on them um when I I
necessary is there any other further
discussion I'm open if not yep Mr
clerk not call a roll thank you Mr chair
Packard oh I'm sorry no
representative
Osborne no representative rice
no Representative Steven Smith no
representative
Sor no representative Cushing yes
representative Sheriff no representative
to7 we're almost
there um Mr chair I I have received a
text message from representative Prout
who informs me that representative
verville is on a work call until 3
o'clock um and is offered to move those
amendments if um you would be willing to
entertain that I leave that to your
discretion
um instead of having to worry about them
at a future meeting we've been here this
long and we've only got what two or
three left or something like that yes
sir all right why don't we why don't we
if if there's no exception uh opposition
from the uh members
uh there's no opposition I I I I
will that this represent Weber I'm just
going to bring up the fact that I have
um a commitment at 230 that I cannot
change and uh all of us have made the
effort to be here and
I am loath to say that I'm happy about a
member who is not here uh when everybody
else has made arrangements to be here um
and I might ask a question M of Mr
Speaker Mr chair yes in just in light of
what representative Weber said uh when
should she should she have to when she
has to leave can representative Smith
step in as an alternate for
her representative Dem Smith no no
marjerie sorry oh no no no no
I'm just saying that in order we would
like to be able to substitute to have a
full to have a full a full contingent no
I I understand um I I I would have to
say at this point no because we haven't
I mean that's been our standing rule
pretty much that you know um we have to
uh be notified beforehand if somebody's
going to be there
um having said that if there's if if
we're not going to be unanimous on on
having that changed then we'll have to
uh deal with this uh at a later basis I
I do plan on having another rules
committee meeting not too far in the
future okay so we will deal with this at
another basis but yeah I um I think that
would
be thank you and I pretty much
against can can I can I do this if we
can get through the other two and get to
this in time is that acceptable before
you have to leave
I I don't want to put roadblocks in
people's way I I um simply want to
apologize it never occurred to me that
this was going to go until 2:30 um I
assumed we were going to be out of here
considerably earlier um I I would urge
the committee uh I know that we use
alternates in various of the other
senior committees I I would urge that
the uh chair consider using alternates
in this committee as well to deal with
these kinds of issues uh which will
arise not only for me but for members of
the majority as well so thank you I
think that's a is that's an issue we can
discuss representative thank you I
appreciate the consideration uh why
don't we move on to um representative
yella Oella and see if we can't get
through this maybe fairly
quickly okay we will bring him in for
just a moment here I will bring his
representative yo Keller are you with us
can you hear me
yes all right
representative thank you uh chairman and
members of the committee I bring this uh
potential rule change uh forward for
your
consideration
uh as you know and have brought up
earlier in this um hearing today uh
there is from time to time especially uh
this
some amount of
of
unknown uh
future ability for this the um sessions
of the full body to
meet how how often it will meet um if we
more fewer sessions longer days kind of
a thing for more opportunities or fewer
opportunities to um to meet because of
the current
situation and there's also a lot of work
that needs to be done
in um executive departments and
administration regard and uh Finance
regarding um
the potential
for gathering
information uh
regarding how covid money was spent um
and policies created around uh covid
especially dur with these
um me many bills having to do with you
know possibly refunding the money uh
that was charged to people for for
disobeying the the guidances or how it
might be affecting
uh different like the Personnel within
Administration um and so there may be
things that
these committees are trying to
address and they may need to request it
in
uh such a way as to be kept private such
a like a sealed um
or trying to gather information which is
part of an um ongoing investigation or
something along those lines or um you
know the cour a court
action and trying to gather that
information um via uh
subpoena however
with with the current rule uh vote of
the entire house would need to vote on
that subpoena action and
so if it's if the um session days for
the Full House are infrequent that may
stifle the potential for these bills to
move forward and make it essentially
impossible for these committees to have
the information needed to make up or
down votes on these bills which may have
the ramification of tur turning a lot of
these bills into study committees where
there's more time to address the issues
and that may leave people
with
their issues un addressed during this
session this um year and
and may be
unnecessarily delayed and so my proposal
is to allow these committees to um to
with a a vote of the committee request
the information that is relevant to
their uh the bills that they are working
on their their authorities within that
committee so that they can do this work
even in the case where uh the full house
is not able to meet or to issue those
those
um subpoenas in a timely fashion so that
they can uh get the work that needs to
be done in the committee's
completed thank you and I'm happy to
take
questions stand up Mr chair uh
yeah can we get a um for discussion
first I'd like to move that we not
accept this okay second second second
thank you uh am I speak to my motion yes
yeah I mean I think that uh there's
nothing that precludes any committee
right now from requesting information to
be provided to it and in almost all
instances I think it's forthcoming um
that having been said the power to
subpoena is an awesome power that ought
to be exercised with I think great
restraint I think the current situation
where a majority of the vote of the
house and the signature of the speaker
are the appropriate means by which we
should have a subpoena issued in the
name of the legislature to give it to a
committee I don't care if it's a
unanimous vote of any committee I wanted
to the P subo to come back before here
and also I think that um it's important
that the rules committee help determine
the form of the subpoena and and and
specify what condition if any are you
know would be uh would condition the
issuance um in use of subpoenas I think
discussion um if I may representative
Osborne thank you so um so a couple
things as I think it's uh probably not
appropriate to uh Grant this kind of
power just to select uh committees uh if
we were really uh going to consider it
it seems like we would you know apply it
equally to to all committees um so I
can't uh you know I haven't been around
as long as you know many of us in in in
my time uh in the house I've only been
involved with a small you know
percentage of of of the work that's been
taken up in that time but I've never
heard of you know any departments or
agencies being not willing to share the
information that they've been requested
of them um and and I believe that uh um
you know setting up an oppositional
posture uh with with a rule change like
this uh is not going to do us any favors
in in being able to to work
cooperatively with them and I think
that's kind of
a a weapon you only pull out at the
least Resort and I I've never seen it
pulled out and uh I hope we don't ever
have to
so it seems to me a dangerous thing to
be
considering that's all share just a a
quick point of reference yes yes Mr
Clark uh the last time that the house
issued a subpoena was during the
impeachment hearings uh back 2000 so the
the the uh um it is representative
Cushing said an awesome um
tool when was that Paul the last time
that was uh the the impeachment of the J
oh just Brock yes I sat on that
committee you uh represent Tim Smith has
his hand up Sir okay representative
Smith Tim Smith I believe or Steve no
it's me thank you Mr chairman okay um I
I'd like to um agree emphatically with
what represent resentative Osborne said
um you know my my primary issue with
this is
not the the topic of reexamining you
know the subpoena power of the house um
you know that's that that's a a separate
discussion that could be had my my
primary issue with this is that it's
reexamining the subpoena power of the
house only for a couple of specific
committees um and that that bothers me
quite a bit I
don't I don't like anything that we put
in rules that makes one committee
special and another committee not
special and and something like this that
would Grant special powers to only a
couple of committees while leaving the
rest to follow a more normal procedure
um it just doesn't make me feel right at
the end of the day so I I can't support
this and I I would very strongly Echo
the concerns that representative Osborne
raised
okay further discussion or okay uh the
motion is to not accept
the Mr clerk would you call the role
please yes sir represent Packard
yes representative
osor yes representative
rice
yes Representative Steven Smith
representative yes representative
Cushing
yes representative schliff
yes wber yes representative Timothy
Smith yes motion to not accept passes
zero okay
this point we have
representative
hor who has an
amendment make sure I can find him here
there he
is representative forgan can you hear us
yes okay and so you're G to share the
amendment on the screen in a moment yep
I'm working on that right now
okay um you want me to start speaking to
it now or should I wait just wait till
the chair recogniz you please oh that
okay Mr chairman by your leave uh go
ahead representative Oregon okay the uh
there the first thing is um this is a
rule 67 and you already passed the rule
67 so in the event that you choose to
move forward this you either have to re
it probably rule 68 or rule 67f whatever
but um basically uh and also a while ago
we had a discussion about guns in the
chamber and people said they needed to
be protected from from violence and
certainly violence is problem in our
society especially gun violence but it
guns are not having a gun is not a
perfect uh is not a perfect precaution
and I admit that masss are not a perfect
precaution but they're way more they're
almost they're extremely but they are
extremely effective so it's it's about I
think it's about 99% or so and certainly
much more effective than a gun is and
against violence and also um you know we
we have the more people are dying every
day than have than died on 9/11 so and
um this depping has killed more people
than any event United States except the
Civil War and the Civil War went on for
four years and the pandemic's only gone
for nine months this is an extremely uh
it's an extremely serious uh threat to
all of us as we know all too well with
the tragic death of Speaker hinch and I
so i' like to thank speaker hinch and
Speaker shirle for the and um and and
yourself Mr chair acting speaker Packer
for the leadership you've shown since
March but I think um one place where we
things fell down a bit was on the issue
of mass I think um and you have good
reasons for doing this but I think you
know we as a house we kind of enabled
the mass refusers more than we needed to
um you know so the majority of us who
take the pandemic seriously and believe
in silence were forced to Comedy those
who uh didn't understand that masss are
necessary for caution um and uh remember
Reverend Step Smith hunt Channel 9 about
Walmart say we can go to meeting in we
can go shop at Walmart why can't we go
to meeting in person now Walmart a
typical Walmart store is the size of the
entire State House campus and there's a
only a few dozen people in there and
they have social distancing and they
have those shelves of goods so it's it's
uh just because so like we need to take
more precaution take a Walmart and
course to Walmart pretty much everyone
if you go into I don't go that often by
go to market Bas and hfer a lot
everybody's messed up they're banging
the lines on the aisle so they're really
most people are not making a big fuss
over the mass requirement it's just sort
of a minority which is uh unfortunately
represented over represented in the in
the house so I'm and right now if you
don't want to be around a bunch of
people wearing masks your only other
choice is to stay home as 130 of us not
including May 130 of us stayed home for
organization day because I didn't
basically um they didn't want to taste
the risk of being infected and a lot of
them would have stayed away even if they
were confident that we were all wearing
masks but um you know probably a large
number of them were there probably just
because of the just because they knew
there was going to be a large mass free
section and the whole thing whole thing
was I think turned the opposite way
around um so those who don't like
wearing masks they expected the rest of
us to accommodate them and I think uh
going forward the house they you know
the people who hate masks and I'm not
really crazy about it myself with always
wearing but the people who think masks
are necessary they hate masks um they
should accommodate the rest of us so if
they want to be pres in person for house
session committee meeting they should
they should wear the mask for the few
hours needed needed for the meeting you
know they can um they can do what they
want once they're back in their cars
once they're driving home but I think uh
I think that's not an unreasonable ask
the they're fairly the only Health um
complications that I've I've seen people
really claim at all you know usually or
hypoxia um you know with CO2 building up
behind the mass or anxiety attacks and I
want to minimize anxiety attacks I
actually had one at the last last house
session because my other the reasons I
was very nervous being downwind from
between 16 80 people who are not messed
up would even more anxious if I known
that um you know our speaker our new
elected speaker going to die in a week
you know that what a horrible that's
like most horrible thing that's happened
to me since I been in the house you know
even regardless of your party we we miss
him terribly and he he did die week
after the meeting I will admit he was
wearing a mask at the meeting so they
don't which proves they're not a perfect
precaution but you know I think I think
they they should accomodate they should
comate us they don't want to run Mass
they can either participate remotely and
I hope we'll expand our remote options
um or they can just stay home because we
we you know we we we is a house we're an
inclusive house we try to accommodate as
many as people's medical conditions as
much as we can but um we can't
accommodate everyone you know certainly
we wouldn't let somebody in the house
who had Ebola you know we wouldn't let
somebody in the house who had you know
Tourette Syndrome um or variety of other
consequen I think it's perfectly
reasonable to require everyone to wear a
mask while they're in the hall you know
it doesn't you can't really force him to
do it outside the hall but um I think
that's a reasonable reasonable ass also
a good example some people call that
virtu signaling but I think setting a
good example is Right term to you
example I don't think it's good for
those pictures we saw dozens of us you
know sitting on the field hockey field
without mass on I think that was just
really appalling and ridiculous and they
look much worse than they thought they
did so not that I haven't looked bad
myself in the past but so that's uh
basically is a mass bill which frankly
has no exemptions um so you you it's
impossible you don't want to take the
risk you know I I think it's probably
just about anyone can at least wear a
plastic face shield you know so
regardless of what
respiratory conditions you have so
that's uh that's my uh that's my bill so
that's basically my uh that's basically
my proposal so it would uh it would
apply not just to U in person session
days but also to committee hearings or
really um any other any other proceeding
which includes as I've heard we had
problems with people going un masked you
know up on the third floor of the state
house um that's a probably probably
should have just read the read the I
probably could explain it quicker just
by reading the whole thing but you all
have it here so that's that's that's my
uh that's my proposal basically mask up
or or stay home which I hate to tell any
M to stay home but um sometime may be
necessary and certainly it's better than
really the terrible situation we had at
the Ford meeting we had a UNH which I
know um PE my constituents are extremely
unhappy that so many unass people were
there and I know UNH isn't happy about
it when you come
we came up with the ingenious slightly
strange proposal to holding on the field
hockey field which luckily we had a nice
day and then there's rumors about we're
gonna try to have a drive-in meeting and
I like I have no no idea how that would
work but I think a simpler simpler thing
if we have have an imp person meeting is
just tell everyone The Mask up and of
course if we can get remote options in
place we should provide those too either
for those who don't feel safe going in
at all those who would be happy to go
but only if we don't make them wear a
mask so they can stay home and be on
mess just as those who worried about
being infected can could participate
remotely and not have to worry about
being infected so that's uh thank you
very much for listening um and uh I know
You' had a long day and a lot to absorb
but um glad you're glad you took the
time to listen to me too and I would be
happy to take any questions if anybody
has
them
I'll move to not accept this okay I'll
second representative Smith moves not to
accept and it's seconded discussion may
I speak to that you may Mr SM repr Smith
thank you Mr chair so
um I get where he's coming from and I'm
sorry he didn't understand some of the
things I said in that interview because
that was a total mischaracterization of
where I'm coming from but we're here to
look at the rules and the technical
parts of it the first vaccine are
already rolling out and it is likely
that while we are still in session we'll
get to a point where the CDC
recommendation is that we don't have to
do the masks anymore but this says the
rule won't repeal until such time as the
state of emergency is lifted or
expires we are likely to maintain the
state of emergency long after the the
need for extensive public protections
are needed just to stay eligible for
federal funding for businesses that have
suffering to extend unemployment
benefits if that's what's required this
doesn't make any distinction there so um
it's you know it's just not ready uh
poorly thought out needs more work can't
vote for it in its current
form Z Tim
Smith thank you Mr chairman um I have a
a question of procedure um for yourself
or possibly for the clerk um and to to
put context where I'm coming from I I
share Representative Steve Smith's
concern um over some of the language my
question is is if the the motion not to
sign off on this were to
fail um would a motion to change the
language then be in order um and
regardless of how that turns out I
believe Mr chairman you mentioned that
we're going to be meeting at least once
more um before the next regular house
session so you know if
if the committee finds itself in in in
agreement with the intent of this but
not the language um there'd be another
attempt for us as the rules committee to
discuss this in the meantime and you
know consider alternative language in
the
future well I I would hope that we'd
always have the chance to uh um you know
discuss you know any issue that's
brought before us I'm sorry my my
apologies to clarify I meant before the
next house session oh before the next
house session
um I I believe we could do that Mr CL
couldn't
we if if you wanna if you want to have
another meeting of the rules committee
that's that's fine we do have uh time we
do not have a a a calendar next week
however we do have one that goes
tomorrow um so if you're looking to
schedule another one um that it really
would have to be either before Thursday
of next week or
uh before Thursday of the the week pre
uh following however we'd need that
notice today uh for or tomorrow at the
latest for for said meeting um I just do
want to clarify one one quick Point um
Mr uh chairman and members of the
committee representative Horgan um at my
suggestion put in that last sentence and
the reason for that was because I I
specifically asked the question along
lines of of what Representative Steve
Smith asked about what happens at such a
time where this rule um you know we we
do pass a point where the CDC changes
its guidelines and um you know this rule
is still on the books requiring members
to uh wear masks and so uh it it at my
sort of uh discussion with him is why he
put that that sentence in there so I
apologize if there's uh any confusion
about that the the uh it seemed at that
time that that sort of seemed like the
logical
thing okay representative Horgan would
like that Mr chair just see yeah the
clerk's the clerk uh summary of how the
Scott Wordsmith is correct that was a
that was a flaw that he saw in the bill
my original thinking was just that we
were probably be eager to repeal this
Mass requirement as soon as we could so
there be no probably be a little
difficulty once everyone's satisfied we
have the all the all clear that wouldn't
be hard to get a two-thirds vote to
suspend the rule and eliminate it but
this is a cleaner way to do it that like
so like it'll automatically Sunset um
when the state of emergency goes
away I'm sure some members will still be
wearing masks like long after the
emergency goes away because I'm sure the
fear habits once acquired die hard and I
think the fear is going to take a long
time to go
away Cushing has his hand up Mr chairman
sir represent cushion you're
muted sorry and while while you know
there is a deadline for uh a house
calendar that goes out tomorrow it
certainly happens all the time not all
the time but there there could be a
supplemental calendar that could be sent
out electronically as as it is if if the
speaker or the chair thought it it would
be important to schedule another rules
uh meeting soon where um assuming if
there are some concerns about how this
language is Wordsmith and the the
sponsor wanted to withdraw it and bring
it back at the next time and maybe
working with other people that could
that could happen and we could still
address the masks in a timely
fashion it's up to the sponsor we can
either vote on it or we can he can
withdraw it like uh uh representative
Prout did for a couple of his to to work
on them and bring them back to us so
it's up to to
sponsor representative Smith has is
Henry's uh which one I'm sorry uh
Timothy oh represent Smith Tim Smith go
ahead thanks um I uh I just want to to
clarify um so that I I know how to vote
on the pending question the pending
question is to not concur with the
language in the amendment um if I my my
understanding is that in order to
introduce an amendment to the amendment
um we would need to be on a question to
correct yes yeah if we're gonna kill it
it's you know we can't amend something
we're GNA kill right okay I just wanted
to make sure um because I I do have some
text changes i' I'd like to propose as
an amendment to the amendment um but I I
don't want to go out of procedure to
attempt that thank you very much if if
representative Horgan does wish to
withdraw for the time being um he he can
certainly do that and you all can
address that offline I mean I'm I'm
amenable to a different mass restriction
so I don't know whether procedurally it
makes any difference
if if I withdraw this motion or whe
whether it it dies and then um a
subsequent similar proposal can be
introduced at a later meeting so I would
also just just State Mr chairman and
members of the committee that even if
the committee does not meet again before
our session of January 6 we do have um
the ability for floor amendments to
house rules um which uh representative
Tim Smith knows about because that's how
he's gotten that rule passed in the past
on a one rule 100 so um you know that is
that is an option uh that if the
committee does not meet the floor
amendments can be
brought uh represent question just a a
question of the chair um do you have in
mind an approximate date when we might
uh reconvene um as a rules committee as
of as of right now no I I'm going to be
conferring with the clerk and um and to
see what um you know what we have ahead
of us and where we're at and that's why
I say we might have one and and again it
might it might be afterwards but uh you
know we'll have to assess where we're at
so I I I don't want to give you a
definitive date right
now I do think too Mr Mr chairman since
uh since you had agreement earlier on to
to extend the date to adopt uh rules uh
beyond the January 5 15th deadline um to
the second session day you know there is
ample time as well for for further
um did did representative hargan are you
going to withdraw this or you want us to
take a vote on it um I would I would be
just as happy to take a take a vote on
it um if there's something
okay we continue a stronger proposal in
the future and of course
also if we if this goes to the floor and
gets voted on that obviously doesn't
affect the next session which is tally
schedule for the anal Recreation Center
un so doesn't either way we either way
um either way that's not going to affect
what the rules are for that session it's
also course it's also do something
probably could be handled you know
culturally within the caucuses you
know
certainly okay Representative Steve
Smith has move to not accept this and
there was a second I'm assuming yes
representative rice okay thank you so
the motion before us is do not accept
this uh Clark will call a roll represent
Packard yes represent
Osborne yes representative rice yes
Representative Steven Smith yes
representative
Sor yes representative Cushing
no Representative
shirtliff no representative Weber has
left the call uh repres Timothy Smith
no a motion to not accept passes 5
to3 I do not have any more amendments to
come at this
time uh Mr chairman
um
the verville has joined us but I don't
not okay
if we
have nothing else in front of
[Music]
us is there any other business to come
before us that
of if not representative Cushing has his
hand up Mr chairman I was in business I
just wanted to thank the chair for uh
the way that you conducted the meeting
today and thank all the other members
who participated in this
well thank you thank you
representative and representative uh
representative Weber had uh texted me to
let me know that she would be leaving
and she asked me to uh just convey her
apologies for to step out well I Ser
rules committees for a number of years
and this is by far the longest meeting
that I've ever been involved
in and now I've been through the longest
session and the
longest uh I'm ready for nap I don't
knowbody else but I'm like
done thank Mr chairman representative
Tim Smith does have his hand up uh okay
representative Tim Smith yeah thank you
I'd just like to to Echo the the other
comments um this is the first uh remote
Committee hearing that that I've
participated in um and I I'd like to say
Mr chairman it went very smooth uh so
thank you for your efforts today um and
to the clerk and the staff for their
work behind the scenes yes well I can't
thank the technician technical people
the most because otherwise you wouldn't
be seeing my face if it hadn't been for
uh the the technical people that got me
on this thing so um and it took quite a
do quite a bit to do that uh so if I can
have a motion to uh second
representative Rice's motion toj yes
right okay oh have do we have to take a
roller call Mr Clerk I guess we do no no
we don't okay that's that's great by bye
bye byebye thank you all I really really
really do appreciate all of you sticking
around and uh going through this it uh
obviously our rules are very important